[Music]
you're listening to radio
sputnik telling
the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
one year on how has boris johnson
done poorly middling or well
how has boris johnson's one year since
his landslide victory in last december's
general election been for you and
whatever happened
to the brexit deadline just like so many
times before
the can has been kicked down the street
maybe even into the long grass
we'll be deep diving into that subject
in the final
hour and who killed pat fanuca
how why and wherefore we'll be looking
at the government's decision
not to give a public inquiry to
fanucan's long-suffering family
in front of whom the belfast lawyer
was cruelly murdered many say
with british state collusion and
speaking of british state collusion
we'll be looking
at the white helmets red faces
who paid for them what were they for and
who
were they really and we'll be looking
with the
diane of british political scientists
professor sir john curtis at the lay of
the political landscape here
in britain and in the united states
talking to
garland nixon about u.s politics but
about venezuela too because
he's just back there as being a
expert invigilator of their
presidential parliamentary elections
oh and a bit about the misgovernance of
scotland
by the snp that's all my responsibility
fasten your seat belts it's going to be
a bumpy ride
at least for some it's rock and roll
radio with pictures
it's the mother of all talk shows
radio sputnik we speak your language the
mother of all talk shows
the only education you can get for free
[Music]
george galloway this
is radio sputnik
and this is london but coming to you of
course all over the world thanks to the
wonders of the
internet and sputniknews.com if you're
listening in the washington dc
area good afternoon president trump you
can listen
in perfect clarity on fm on 105.5
if you're elsewhere in the united states
you can listen from burning city to
burning city
from coast to coast on am you can listen
all over the world on the aforementioned
sputniknews.com
but if you are one of the more than half
a million
people who every week watch the show
as well as listen then listen
to this if you are watching on facebook
please take this moment to share with
all of your friends
all of your contacts whether you're
watching on my
own facebook page or on rt's
multiple facebook pages ditto
on youtube if you're watching on my
youtube channel please
subscribe while you're at it it's over a
hundred thousand subscribers
now i expect but you can also watch on
rt's multiple youtube channels you can
watch
on twitter you can watch on instagram
you can even watch
on twitch however you're listening
however you're watching this is
a global but open university of the
airwaves there are no
tuition fees and you are positively
encouraged to speak
back to the teacher whatever your point
of view
it will be entertained here it might be
demolished
but it will be at least heard it will be
entertained
this is a truly global show
we'll be talking about the united states
we'll be talking
about syria we'll be talking about
venezuela we'll be talking about britain
we'll be talking
about the european union and we'll be
talking
about scotland or at least i will be
in many respects last week was a normal
week in the minority snp
government-controlled
scottish political landscape by normal i
mean that
the husband of the first minister
of the country who is the chief
executive
of the snp the ruling party
although they share a duvet there ain't
no
pillow talk at least that's what they
want you
to believe the contradictory
evidence given to the alex salmond
inquiry
at hollywood the scottish parliament
grew to monstrous some would say
ridiculous
proportions in the testimony given
by the aforementioned first husband
peter muddle his name is though
no one had ever heard him speak before
until
he appeared at the inquiry and actually
many now regret ever having heard him
he certainly regrets ever having spoken
because the first thing he did was
flatly contradict
the sworn evidence given by his wife
the first minister and leader of the snp
nicola sturgeon cards on the table i
have said
from the beginning before the trial that
the snp conspired to send
alex salmon to prison for the rest of
his life just think about that he said
to me in this very
building we've all been in politics a
long time
i sat in parliament with alexander for
decades
we all know about inner party struggles
but we've never had a situation where
your opponents
in your own party are trying to send you
to
prison now alex almond is 66 he would
not have survived
a sentence of several years in prison
if that had been the outcome of his
trial it was not
he was acquitted on all charges
as i always proclaimed that he
would be but that was just the battle
not the war as many people now know
the snp were determined to
continue the persecution of alexander
and he was equally determined to hold to
account
those who had conspired to destroy
not his political career but to destroy
his very life now they set up an inquiry
and it's gone nowhere it's been
stonewalled it's been crab walked
it has been uh sabotaged at
every turn but the truth will out
and there are not many people now paying
attention
in scotland at least who don't believe
that there's a cover-up of enormous
proportions
going on and of course we all know
since richard nixon and the watergate
it's the cover-up
that brings them down in the end and i
firmly believe for again full disclosure
i have a dog in this fight i'm involved
in this fight i've got skin in this
fight
and i'll take calls from anyone who
thinks differently
to what i'm about to say in fact they'll
be prioritized
so on your marks get set
the reality is that the snp does not
deserve
to continue in governance in scotland
i don't have time to adam break
the series of disasters over the corona
virus over the nike conference outbreak
which was covered up
and if it hadn't been covered up there
wouldn't have been an international
rugby match
played at murrayfield nearby and if
there hadn't been
an international rugby match played at
murrayfield in edinburgh far fewer
people would have caught the coronavirus
and the crisis would not
have left scotland the second worst
performer in all of europe
the second worst arguably per million
and bear in mind scotland is a huge
country with a small
population we ought to have been one of
the best
we are actually almost the worst
in the entire world
there's the collapse of the
scottish government owned fabrication
yard
in the northeast of scotland about which
more
later there's the fiasco of the
ferries this is scotland the country
which on the clyde
built great ocean going liners which
sailed the seven seas in the 19th
century
when the americans were still cowboys
the sparks of the workshop of the world
could be seen on the cloud in glasgow
and the manufacturers then taken
across the world by scottish built ships
we've tried to build
two ferris they are now years
over the date that they were supposed to
be fabricated by
and they have cost five times the money
that was budgeted for them there's a
sick children's hospital in
edinburgh which has never opened there's
the
devastation of the scottish economy
by the play acting of nicola sturgeon
with her determination to do anything
that boris johnson does on
a uk level differently whether it's
likely to be worse
does not matter what matters is that
it's
different and so scotland has a
bewildering
series of tears tears of a clown
which make it impossible for commerce
for
business for industry to carry out their
normal business it has devastated
the scottish economy the divisions
created by the hate bill
that we discussed here some weeks ago
the divisions caused by a government
which has
only one task it seems not
education as they promised that's going
down
the tubes not the health service i've
already told you
about the state of that it has only one
purpose to deepen division on this small
island of english-speaking people
pursuant to their only policy
which is to sever britain
along the scottish english border
their goons are out there
at that border hurling abuse at
english people whether they're bringing
money to spend
or whether they are conducting trade
because of course
more than 60 percent of scotland's trade
is not with slovenia or slovakia
but with the rather closer england
and wales for that matter that would all
just be a normal week
but here's what happened this week first
of all
the snp government lectured
the heir to the throne and his wife
prince william and kate
that they should not have made a journey
to edinburgh which they did
to thank the national health service
staff
on behalf of the queen on behalf of the
british
state the scolding
would have been demeaning even if it had
been
right but it was wrong
prince william was on a working visit to
edinburgh a working visit to edinburgh
is perfectly within even the byzantine
laws laid down by nicola sturgeon's
snp then
this day they have warned
how's that for less a majesty they have
warned prince charles and his wife
not to come to balmoral for christmas
as would otherwise have been their
want let's say majesty for sure
but how about this one when boris
johnson said that the royal navy
would be deployed to protect british
waters in the event of a no deal brexit
and the ongoing propensity
of continental industrial trawlers
some of them firing electronic jolts
to stun the fish the better to hoover
them up
that the royal navy would be deployed to
protect
britain's territorial waters
now whatever you think of that as a
negotiating tactic
it's abundantly clear at least to most
of us
that scotland is still in britain
therefore
any waters off the coast of scotland are
british
territorial waters in fact a lot of the
fish
that have been hoovered stunned and
hoovered
are fish in the scottish part of british
territorial waters
johnson actually fighting for the
interests of scottish
and the scottish coastal communities
and therefore tactically he said well
we'll put our royal navy ships on
alert along comes
admiral of the rear end
somebody called mike russell who's never
done a day's work in his life
a day's service in his life wouldn't
know one
end of a foxhill from another he
announces
not in scotland you won't now
the scottish parliament is a devolved
assembly
scotland decided to be a part of britain
and by a big margin a once-in-a-lifetime
referendum
just six years ago and now we have
an oath an oath
mike russell telling the royal navy
where it can go
and where it cannot and the british
government doesn't say
or do that about it
now i'm not a royalist
i'm a republican neither am i the
greatest cheerleader
for recent deployments post-second world
war
of the royal navy but i do live in
britain
i am a british citizen i recognize
that we have a british head of state
and a british government who've got a
navy
as a matter of fact i helped that that
navy should be built
in scotland very largely as the member
of parliament for the yard that built
the frigates
i was forever at the door of
conservative government ministers
encouraging them you might put it that
way brow beating them
they might have put it that those
frigates should be built on the
cloud but
because i recognize that i do live
in the state called britain
the united kingdom i recognize that it
has
a navy that it can send wherever it
wants
and no jumped up town councillor in an
ikea parliament
called the scottish shortbread senate
can say or do anything about it last
point
but i don't want to abuse my platform
i spoke this afternoon to a scottish
holier who in desperation raised the
following with me
he's trying to move by wide
load truck
a one and a half million pound cargo
of scottish manufactured equipment
to southampton and thence to the
continent
he was worried about the brexit deadline
now past or rather now postponed
but he was also worried about the
demurrage
costs of the ship in southampton
waiting for his load if
his load was leaving from carlisle
it would have been perfectly proper for
him to hire a commercial
escort service to guide him down
the motorway under government
regulations
that would have been the way to do it
but in nicholas sturgeon
scotland only the police
can guide you down the jewel carriageway
until you get to carlyle
so he tried to book the police it's a
booking by the way
it's a commercial revenue stream for the
scottish police
which has been centralized by the way
into one police force
that means there's only one commander
that you've got to well
control if you're the scottish
government
the police must do it the police earn
big money from it but the police can't
do it
until after christmas thus this hollier
faces ruin and the
manufacturer of the equipment
will never get another order from the
european company that ordered
manufactured goods
made in scotland how's that for
a government that understands business
understands the need for exports
understands the need for manufacturing
this is an absolute scandal and i
am going to do everything i can in the
course of this coming week
to bring unbearable pressure to bear on
the
scottish police police scotland they
must make officers
available or they must relinquish their
monopoly rights
to escort this vehicle from the
northeast of scotland
to the scotland england border
i tell you that story not just because
it's personal to me
but because it sums up in one nutshell
at the extent to which scotland
is governed by clowns who've never done
our days real work in their life
who have never run a student union
coffee store
who know nothing about business nothing
about industry
nothing about manufacturing and
everything they touch
turns to dust or murder
as the french say i'll be right back
this is
the mother of all talk shows radio
sputnik
[Music]
we are above all the latest developments
and we don't take any sides
radio sputnik telling the untold
hello people of britain your prime
minister
here not only am i helping british
people get its fish back
but i'm helping these fine gents get
their fish supper
isn't that right my wet seafaring
friends how about bloody time they
showed up north and did something
yes sir a mushy piece
battered cod quintessential british pub
grub
even hoping to see some sexy mermaids
just don't tell carrie
incoming
[Music]
garlic boys it's time to do some farting
oh look another ship
ah boris didn't they know that i've been
farting buggers off since 1972
it's kind of to get our waters back
cocker yes quite well
i've come prepared
i'm ready to defend british waters
where's the end in the pockets turn that
bloody music off and take that bloody
ass off
come on get the finger out i'm
channeling my
inner horatio nelson
valga down with the french ships and all
that great
british history man the cannons i put
that bloody champagne down here it's off
do some bloody work for christ's sake
i hereby christen this vessel hms
victory quick somebody threw him
overboard
you're listening to radio sputnik
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
now you can vote on my paul one year on
how
has boris johnson done a poorly
57 b middling
28 c well
15 more than 1 000 people have voted
already in the first 20 minutes you can
vote
on my twitter feed at george galloway
with a blue tick
and now i've got so much uh in the way
of social media but it's a tight
ship tonight because we've got so many
outstanding
guests and the first of those is garland
nixon
uh the finest independent political
analyst and commentator
in the united states garland nixon the
coolest of cats
is just back from venezuela but first i
want to ask him
what's happening in washington dc
garland welcome back
it's very nice to see you hail and
hearty
i understand there were some
difficulties getting out of venezuela
we'll come back to
that but uh washington first
it's all over for the donald trump
challenge
to the election result isn't it how is
he taking it
as of tomorrow the um the electors will
meet the electoral college will meet and
they will
do the i mean what's considered the
final selection of the president
and it is certainly expected that joe
biden will
win here's what's interesting about that
you know the complaints by the media
the complaints by the democrats that
donald trump won't give in
i want to read you a quote from hillary
clinton anyone can go on
online and find this quote joe biden
should not concede
under any circumstances because i think
this is going to drag out
and eventually i do believe he will win
if we don't give an
inch and if we are focused and as
relentless as the other side
is so for all they're complaining about
donald trump i think it's interesting
that we saw
four years of a of a russia gate hoax
where
they dragged this thing out for four
years now they're complaining that john
uh that
excuse me that donald trump is pushing
uh you know an argument that doesn't
have a lot
of legal foundation he hasn't been very
successful i agree with that i'm not a
trump fan
but it's interesting that when you look
at that quote hillary clinton had made
it clear
that her position was what donald trump
is doing is exactly what she thought
that joe biden
um should do so it's quite hypocritical
for them to you know kind of throw their
hands up in the air and
and be so upset when in fact that was
their plan if they had lost
the democrats hypocritical who'd have
thunk that
uh let me ask you about arizona about
georgia rather
um there's uh two by-elections four
senate seats there
on those by-elections turns the
majority in the senate the republicans
on
the face of it seemed well enough placed
to hold on to both seats and thus
control
of the senate but i watch donald trump's
twitter feed
and even hear some of his uh statements
he's laying into the republican party in
georgia with a vengeance
is he trying to throw those two
by-elections do you think
you know i don't know that the intent is
there um i think
donald trump is you know that's about
donald trump that's about you know his
anger
um i don't you know whether or not he's
intending it is
is i think is irrelevant i think that
could very well be the outcome
there's a lot of disrupt disruption in
the republican party right now
um both of the uh in in both of those
senate races the democrat
is a is uh has has a slight lead um it's
within the margin of error but because
of the
the level of disruption in the um
republican party you know normally i
came on and i said i think the
the republicans win both of these
because it's a because it's a reliably
rich state but right now
um i'm guessing that the democrats have
a good chance of winning this
and then of course that begs the
question
all three parts of the american
government and thus
have nowhere to hide from an angry
public
uh who are not satisfied what he's doing
yeah because here's the problem i think
joe biden's policies whether he has the
senate or not
um are the same joe biden is you know
quite honestly
he is part of the far right wing of the
democratic party and these days
that's saying something you know as far
right as the party has gone so he
doesn't have a foil he can't go in there
and say well i can't get this stuff
through
because the republicans are going to
stop me there are many people here who
believe that the democrats would
prefer to lose both of these um
you know fundamentally uh they're
they're you know the the leaders of the
party and the people who support the
party the
uh the oligarchs um who financially
support the party would much prefer a
divided congress so they could make an
argument to continue to get
um uh conservative policies to push
austerity neoliberalism because that's
what they want to do anyway and joe
biden's history says
that's what he wants to push what's the
future for the republican party i see
chris christie talking about moving on
from the trump era uh of course
people like bush and those around them
uh openly
wished for biden to beat trump
is the republican party going to stick
with trump
or at least with trump-ism or is it
going to
split you know it's funny i'm looking at
it and i see a possibility for both
parties to split
in that the republican party has
problems because it's not the party of
the republicans now the supporters of
the party mostly are trump supporters
and beforehand before
trump came onto the scene the reason
that donald trump
won was because so many of the
supporters
were becoming more populous they were
getting you know
they were uh starting to get sick of
neo-liberalism unfortunately donald
trump
you know told him he was something else
but he gave them neoliberalism on
steroids
i suspect donald trump is going to stay
in the picture and that the republicans
who are in office are still going to
have to constantly give a hit not to
donald trump because if they go back to
their respective districts
the people there are going to support
donald trump i i would imagine he's
still going to have rallies
he's still going to talk about 2024. so
their party has some serious problems
however the democratic party has real
problems too because
they won and they got joe biden and joe
biden is going to be problematic
for their party he's already started i
mean he had there's there's
um some uh uh audio on the internet
where he was talking to civil rights
leaders or some civil rights activist at
least
he's screaming and yelling at him and
sounding like a madman so
uh the democratic party is i think right
now
going to be moving in the direction to
get wiped out in the midterms but wiped
out by whom
here's here's my prediction instead of
looking at the democratic party and the
republican party in a traditional way
going into the midterms and from that
one look at them in the primaries
i think a whole bunch of traditional
conservatives and republican
excuse me republicans and democrats in
the primaries is where they're going to
get wiped out
very interesting now uh joe biden has a
son
hunter biden uh we spoke
uh when this uh story of his laptop
first broke
and we thought it might be even a game
changer because
well it was pretty hair curling stuff
and then the entire american media
and the so-called social media which
turns out
not to be social at all uh
it's uh as closely controlled now
as the so-called mainstream media uh
deliberately suppressed the story but
now it's back they can no longer
suppress it and hunter biden is
under fbi investigation
what can you tell us about that well a
couple of things you know if
you remember we were told that it was um
hunter biden has admitted that we were
told that his russian disinformation so
i guess hunter biden must be pushing
russian disinformation on himself
according to social media in the
mainstream media but in reality
you know hunter biden can't be feeling
too bad right now i mean let's be honest
from what we've seen
it appears quite likely that he was
involved in some uh
some business activities that are
questioned that are legally questionable
to say the least
but his dad's going to be president and
it certainly also looks like
in in some areas his dad was getting a
cut so if i'm in trouble if i've got
some crooked business dealings
i'm feeling not all that bad if my dad
is in charge of the department of
justice and there you go that's that's
the problem right there
i mean that's going to be a huge problem
but i really don't think the bidens care
based on what i've seen
and let's be honest the media social
media etc
it's just going to protect them the
story might disappear we might just if
it may be like the guy's name eric
charmela you might not even be able to
say
uh hunter biden anymore on social media
or you know you'll lose your account
i i suppose joe could pardon him that's
what
donald seems to be uh intent on doing
pardoning his own children well yeah
you know what but here's the thing about
it you know uh um uh if you look i mean
we can look at clinton
um uh uh um uh bill clinton pardoning
march
mark rich under questionable
circumstances we go back to
uh george bush senior pardoning
everybody who was involved in the iran
contra uh
scan uh you know uh of illegal actions
including
eliot abrams who is back today so for
the p for
for uh politicians to argue that
uh donald trump is you know is doing
something extraordinary pardoning
whoever
i think is absurd i mean i'm not for any
of that or
that's the way the game is played as i
see it if he does it
that's just the way the game is played
now they're all up in arms just because
donald trump is
is doing it now as i said earlier
garland you were
uh an observer in vigilator
uh at the venezuelan elections i myself
was during uh the last election
of hugo chavez uh what was the outcome
how satisfied were you with what
happened
you know uh of course uh maduro and his
party won
you know they've got like 67 percent of
the vote it was it was incredi you know
a big blow out what's interesting about
this is that the united states arguing
that it was a fraudulent election
if we remember back in 2016 the hillary
clinton argued that it was a fraudulent
election it was terrible you couldn't
trust it and then the opposition party
won and the next day she says hey it was
a perfectly clean pristine election
everything worked
so you know i i you have to take
anything that
uh mike pompeo and people like that say
with a grain of salt
i was there look everybody
in the in everybody in uh venezuela
when you become a teenager i think it's
either 14 or 16. you get an id
it has your signature it has your thumb
print when you go
to the voting booth you have to give
them the id and then you put your
thumb on a machine who identifies you
you then vote
and they uh give you a printed ballot
which you sign
how do you cheat that if anybody doesn't
believe that they're
um uh uh that their vote was valid you
can literally go back and count vote by
vote
with the people's signatures on it it's
absurd and the machines are unhackable
because they use old technology they
can't be connected to the internet
so you can't get in them to hack them i
was there i went from one end of that
um a voting process to the other there
is one
governmental organization the cne that
sets it up
nationwide they do everything in every
booth the same way
and at the end of the voting process
they audit
the entire voting process and they
stream the audit live
online it is the cleanest voting process
i've ever seen you'll notice
that the people who are saying that that
that their voting process
uh was not legal none of them are saying
okay well let us come in
and let us audit it because they already
invited them in and said you can observe
it while it's going on
they're just going to say it's no good
and we already know if the opposition
had won which there's no chance of that
that they would have said everything's
pristine and in fact what we have now
is the a former leader of the opposition
i think his name is capriles i'm not
pronouncing it right
yes he's he's now saying look this biden
thing was not working it's a joke we
need to go in another direction and it's
it's a sad state of affairs i watched it
it was clear
clean and i went out to the towns and
talked to people
and i saw it number one they're
suffering not from socialism from
sanctionism
from the sanctions the horrific
sanctions that the u.s
is putting on venezuela they're
sanctioning a country that's mostly
brown people
they're trying to starve these people
out and it is it is i mean it's nazi
level evil what's going there for me to
be on the ground
and say that a government is trying to
feed their people they're trying to help
their people
and the u.s is starving them and mike
mike pompeo literally tweeted
no food no medicine next no excuse me no
food no medicine no power
next no no maduro so they're trying to
starve the people out
but these people have a tough spine they
shook their fists and they said we'll
protect our democracy i don't see
the venezuelan people giving in but it's
it's i mean it's just
unacceptable the vicious nazi level evil
that the united states is putting on
these people with sanctions
it's going to be a dilemma not just for
your government
but for ours which only this week
re-plighted its trough to juan guado
that the biden administration is being
asked
by capriles who was the candidate
against chavez
in 2012 in the election i monitored
myself
is saying you need to give up on this
one guido guy
only months ago they were trying to hand
over the gold
of venezuela in the bank of england to a
guy
that the venezuelan opposition is now
saying is a total failure and has to be
abandoned if the american government and
the british government are now forced
to abandon guido having tried to make
him a multi-billionaire
with venezuela's gold that's going to be
hard to explain
well if you look at the trajective
trajectory of things here
leading all the way up to the election
where the venezuelan people have made
their presence known internationally and
they brought in observers and everybody
could see what was happening
unfortunately the u.s doesn't care
because because here's the bottom line
they want the oil and they're willing to
do whatever they need to do to get it
they'll starve these people
if they have to starve them to death all
the better they've moved the dead bodies
out of the way so you can pump the oil
it is
it is getting blatantly obvious the
hypocrisy here where the u.s is arguing
where we have voting machines there's no
paper trail
there is no way we simply have to trust
that our
intelligence agencies and nefarious
actors will not hack into those machines
even though they're easily hackable
we've got to trust that it's fair but
people who have
a paper ballot that you can easily uh
audit
that they're they're all liars and and
if you look at there's two things
the two countries that the us is moving
on for regime change
one of them has the the the uh
the largest oral reserves in the world
that would be venezuela the other has
the fourth largest oral reserves in the
world that would be iran that's that's
not an accident it's not an accident and
i think the world knows what's going on
and i think that the us is an oil
company with an army
well as uh donald rumsfeld famously said
it's not our fault that god put
america's oil under
other people's countries garland nixon
as always
fantastic to see you glad thank you you
got back
uh safely now this week was the
15th birthday of rt
happy birthday rt i made a short about
it take a look
i've made well over a thousand
broadcasts on rt
over the last decade or so in the same
period of time
i haven't made 10 on the bbc
and that's just one of the reasons why
i'm so happy
that rt is 15 years old
this week
[Music]
i'm celebrating the birthday partly
because
rt allows a second opinion and we all
know
what happens when there is no second
opinion what happens is well
the invasion of iraq the deaths of a
million people
and all on a mountain of lies
about wmd and the same could be said
about many other conflicts about many
other issues rt allows people
a voice outside of the prevailing
orthodoxy and it's remarkable how
often those voices turn out to be right
and the bbc's orthodox turns out to
be wrong you don't have to agree
with every editorial line or slant
coming out of rt i myself
don't although i agree of course with
most of it
there's nobody rt telling you
what to say that isn't the case i assure
you
at the bbc even if you can get onto it
rt has been a global success story of
enormous proportions and that's why
the powers that be hated so much
it's not just the english language or
the arabic language
or the spanish language or the german
language or the portuguese language or
i've lost count of the number of
language services
now emanating from rt
it is a global success story
in a time when other global media
outlets like cnn for example
are virtually sunk they'd be on sale
if only anyone would buy them rt
investigates rt questions more
and moreover it challenges you to
question more isn't that a good thing
wouldn't we be better
governed if we questioned more
wouldn't we be better informed if
instead of reading and listening and
watching
to the prevailing orthodoxy we got
an alternative take an alternative point
of view
wouldn't we be all much better
off we often hear fake
news about russia its
economies the size of italy they lie
it's uh somehow other
out of europe when in fact russia is the
biggest european country
moscow is the biggest city in europe
just think about that in fact most
countries
in the world i mean most countries in
the world
would rather have president putin as
their leader than the leaders that
they've got
most countries in the world would think
themselves lucky if their foreign policy
was being guided by mr lavrov
rather than the foreign minister that
they have got
russia is a big power an economic
big power a military superpower
and now it has in all these languages
a reach in the media market commensurate
with
a country that is a big power
and you know how effective it is because
they're always trying to close it down
always trying to
discredit it they often try to say that
we are
state-controlled media in fact they flag
us up
as such on social media but none of
these
tactics of vilification even
suppression have remotely worked
if you look at the billions of views
of rt's output around the world you can
see that it's green cheese
as much as anything else that fuels the
antipathy
towards rt in other media outlets
we now know that outfits like the
integrity
initiative and the 77th brigade
are subterranean secret
and secretly funded ways that the
british
state attempts to get its narrative
over we're nothing like that
we're open and honest we are
our team and what we say we're ready
to be quizzed questioned interrogated
and criticized for you couldn't say the
same about the backstairs media
being funded by states like britain
so i'm really proud uh to have been
associated with
rt throughout most of its 15 years
of existence and i look forward to many
many
more years i believe by the time i
no longer have a face fit for television
the rt
will be the biggest broadcaster in the
whole world
i really mean that i really hope that so
happy birthday
sweet 15 rt
have something to say do you disagree
with george
then call us now and give us your view
now by all means give us your views uh
however contrary
they might be you can call us from the
uk
on oh 2077 982
255 or from the u.s
on zero zero one seven five seven
seven four four four four eight
zero or you can tweet us of course at
george galloway
at rt uk news the poll is raging
one year on how is boris johnson done a
poorly 57 percent down one
b middling 28
c well 15 that's up
one i'd love to hear from people who
think boris johnson's done well
over the last year uh that's simply
bamboozling
uh to me but uh if you are one of those
bao means call
and tell us why now i was
in the committee room corridor
when douglas hogg mp as he then was
now lord hilsham made a statement
on behalf of the government during
the passage of a bill which would
require people
in northern ireland to swear oaths of
allegiance
to the crown in the course of his
remarks
douglas hogg said that there were some
solicitors in northern ireland that were
far too close to their clients
i bearded him at the end of the
committee
session and told him in terms that he
had just signed
a death warrant for some solicitors
in northern ireland and so it came to
pass not once not twice
but more often even than that
one of the cases that affected me the
most
was the mother of patrick fanuca
patrick fanucan was gunned down at the
kitchen table
in front of his wife and then small
children
one of them now a member of parliament
but his children
and his wife had to watch their husband
their father
bleeding to death on the kitchen floor
in fact mrs fanucan was also shot and
wounded
in the murderous attack it was
immediately suspected
quickly concluded and now overwhelmingly
undeniably the case
that patrick fanoukan like rosemary
nelson and many many
others were murdered perhaps
at the hands of loyalist paramilitaries
about with the collusion of british
state
authorities this much has been admitted
by no less than
david cameron by the british state at
all
levels but the attempt
to get a public inquiry into the mother
of patrick vanuken
ran into rocks this week
when the government refused to allow
such an inquiry to proceed the struggle
for such an inquiry to provide closure
to the family to
assure or otherwise the
public in britain and in northern
ireland about what was happening
in the very recent past very recent
past talking about the 1990s
and the role that our
state forces played in
collusion with loyalist killers
in the murder of innocent catholic
people
like patrick fanookan malachy o'doherty
is a journalist and author he has a new
book
out in august the year of chaos
which follows the period of greatest
violence
in northern ireland through memoir and
interviews mal's a good talker that's
why he's here
on the mother of all talk shows mal
o'doherty thank you for uh joining us uh
talk us through what happened on that
grim day
with patrick fanucan first will you
well you've done it very well yourself
george it was
um in the evening a sunday evening they
were sitting down to
tea it was i think a month short of
patrick fanoogan's
40th birthday it was the third
known attempt to kill him we
although we haven't had a public inquiry
and the family is very determined that
there should be one and
and and that's all debutable but
although we haven't had that we have had
an incredible document
from qc hired by david cameron as prime
minister
that's qc desmond de silva which is a
very substantial document looking at the
intelligence information
of the time it does confirm a huge
amount of state collusion
in the killing of pathfinding but it
also takes us back through other
incidents
and it gives us a character of the or a
sense of the
the activities and the thinking within
the ruc special branch the police
special branch
uh the forced research unit of the army
the british army which was actually
denying
that it was running agents and was
running brian nelson
a major agent involved in this killing
and with the mi5 or the security service
as as desilva calls them let me give you
an idea
in about 1981 when the first report came
that there was a plan being prepared to
kill
pat fanouken one of the thoughts that
special branch had was that
they should set up a phony attack on him
to freak him out to scare him from his
home
and that would be the device by which
they would save him from a genuine
attack
that was the kind of carry-on they were
they were discussing and thinking about
they didn't do that and the attack that
seemed to be underway at that time
did not go ahead nor did the second the
third one
was set up very largely by an army agent
called
brian nelson he was an agent employed by
the british army
to basically target people from inside
the ulster defense association
a loyalist paramilitary organization and
his report
was passed a special branch that
preparations were being made
uh to kill jerry adams
and if you leave the silver the silver
report there
it recounts the three attempts made to
kill jerry adams
now what de silva found or what he had
said very very strongly
well he states it fairly explicitly is
that someone in special branch
redirected those who wanted to kill
adams towards pat fanucan
and you have to under why did they do
that well the the army themselves
de silva has the documentation say that
um
essentially the army concluded that it
was unthinkable that you would
collude in the killing of a candidate
for the british parliament
that this would be an attack on
democracy itself
and you have to ask yourself is that a
plausible uh
reason for selecting one target over
another
because uh essentially you know the
argument
that you would be caught killing anybody
is one that you might be arrested and
you might be convicted and your whole
project might be might be scandalously
uh
debunked and disclosed but there's no
doubt that in some measure pat falugan
took the bullet for jerry adams
and let's look back at the successive
attempts to kill jerry adams and i'm
taking
that most of your viewers know that
jerry adams was the president of
schinfian
and has been described variously as a
leading member of the ira though he's
often denied that
right the first attempt to kill jerry
adams was when he was returning
from a court case in april i believe
when he was shot and but he wasn't
seriously wounded
because apparently the guns were
tampered with
a friend of mine a man that i spoke to
about that visited one of those wounded
in that attack
two weeks afterwards he was sitting in a
hospital bed in a bullet between
hit him between his eyes and had done no
harm
particularly great harm and and that led
him to the conclusion that
these weapons had been tampered with the
second attempt to
kill jerry adams was organized by brian
nelson
who was the agent being run by the
british army and this was an attempt
that the army themselves intercepted and
the idea then was jerry
adams was driving around at that time
towards the housing executive office
using a black taxi like a london hackney
cab
and the plan was to drive up on a
motorbike put olympic mine
on the roof of the cab clear off and and
kill him with an explosion on the roof
the army decided as well as a outline
that
that it was best to intercept this so
they flooded the area with troops
and then when it comes to the third
attempt it appears and this is to
silva's understanding
that brian nelson no one agent of the
british army
ostensibly involved in the
targeting advice to the loyalist
paramilitaries so that those
targeting so those attacks could be
intercepted
nelson was himself actually keen to kill
republicans
and they didn't want to kill adams so
special branch
said this is a guy that's quite
interesting
this guy's an intelligence officer for
the ira
this guy handles their money you know
this guy handles their investments
now the chief constable of the ouc
denied that patrick faneuken was a
member of the ira
anthony mcintyre a friend of mine who
was in the ira says that he was never
given to understand as a member that pat
vanuguen was himself a member
though two of his brothers were members
but you don't necessarily
do what your brothers do and um
but we have this document that was
inside a special branch
that said fluken was an intelligence
officer
and a nudge and a great degree of
facilitation of the gunman
uh to carry out with the attack and what
did silva find further more was that
there were numerous
attacks threats reported to them
of likely attacks by paramilitaries and
the general thinking within the police
force
of northern ireland the ruc as it was
called at the time
within the special branch the secret
service of the police force was that if
somebody was a thorn in their side
if somebody was a bit of a nuisance then
you let the killing go ahead
you didn't intervene right and that
applied also to the killing of loyalists
by the way
that that was that was fine but so this
is the kind of thing that was going on
uh at that time the falugan family and i
don't speak for them and i'm sure they
they wouldn't want me to convey the
impression that i was speaking for them
but i suspect that the difference
between what we have in the silver
which is an extraordinary report an
amazing report
that what they want that's not there is
they want
i think validation of their belief
that the order to kill pat finukin came
from the top
that the the the douglas hogg's uh
reference to him was as you called it a
death sentence
that perhaps margaret thatcher herself
was uh was involved
there's questions over that and one of
the questions the the
legitimate doubts i think over that is
that
special brands themselves were
repeatedly asking the government
three times asked the government to
provide guidelines for the running of
the agents
who were themselves carrying out
criminal
offenses including murder and three
times the government refused to give
those guidelines
and it does seem that rather than
someone in government saying get rid of
him
take him take him take him what he said
was look
you get on with what you have to do and
don't bother us with the details
i think that's what was implied in the
refusal to give
precise guidance to special branch on
the running of agents
and and in the covering up of the crimes
committed by agents
we use that word collusion there's
different definitions of that around
one definition of it is essentially that
and this is the one used in early
inquiries
by stevens and by corey that essentially
it's
covering up after the fact you know but
i mean
de silva went further to talk about a
collusion which is
a form of connivance that you're
actually in there
you're you're not just turning a blind
eye knowing that someone's going to be
killed
you're actually in some measure
instrumental in facilitating it
and and the pathfinding case is a very
uh stark example of that and i would
commend to everybody
to just google it to silver report i've
registered
and i i was actually you agree with me
george it's extraordinary
it is i was rather impressed i must say
only time ever uh with david cameron's
uh apologia in introducing the
report in the house of commons in in 45
seconds all we've got left mal
tell us about your book coming out in
the summer
the year of chaos published by atlantic
we're looking back at the period between
the introduction of internment in august
and operation motorman the the
saturation by the military of the
of the no go areas in in july of 72.
and there will be there's you know it's
a broad look it's not
it's not a particular attack on one side
but certainly one element that comes
through very strongly
is is the blundering and the ineptitude
and the barbarism of of some elements
within the army
but my my own analysis and people have
clashed with me on it is that
a prime minister within this is the ira
and the silva himself says let's not
forget
they killed more people than anyone else
and none of this would have happened but
for that
that's my analysis but the book will
have much in it to yeah
i think it's going i think it's an
exploration through
interviews and through the archives that
will give a very very clear picture
of of quite extraordinary uh activity
and on all fronts
look forward to reading it malachi or
doha thank you very much indeed
for joining us on the mother of all talk
shows
i've missed my uh eight o'clock deadline
but here
is the news with jamie lowe
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news the final deadline
in talks between the united kingdom and
the european union turned out not to be
once more in a joint statement british
prime minister boris johnson
and european commission president ursula
vonda lyon said it was responsible
at this point to go the extra mile the
pair discussed major unresolved topics
during their call
the two sides had said that sunday was
to be the deadline for a decision
on whether to continue with talks with
the uk set to leave the eu rules
at the end of the month the leaders
agreed to tell negotiators to carry on
talks in brussels to quote
see whether an agreement can even at
this late stage to be reached
they did not say how long these latest
talks would continue but the ultimate
deadline is the 31st of december
and time must be allowed for the uk and
european parliaments to vote on any deal
that emerges before then vandalian said
sunday's call with johnson had been
quote constructive and useful
but johnson repeated his warning from
earlier in the week that a no deal
scenario was most likely
the uk and the eu have been carrying out
negotiations for a post-brexit trade
deal since march and are attempting to
secure one before the so-called
transition period
end on the 31st of december when two
sides would move to trading on world
trade organization rules
without a trade deal tariffs which are
charges on goods being
brought and sold between the two sides
could be introduced
and in turn prices on certain products
may go up
thousands of donald trump supporters
alleging electoral fraud converged on
several u.s cities and towns on saturday
and there were isolated scuffles with
counter-demonstrators
in washington dc more than 20 people
were arrested and four people were
stabbed police said
trump lost the november 3rd election to
joe biden but
is yet to concede the electoral college
the system which elects u.s presidents
is due to endorse mr biden's victory
tomorrow
biden won 306 votes to mr trump's 232 in
the electoral college
and gained over 7 million more votes
than his republican
rival in the popular vote however trump
shows no signs of acknowledging reality
as he continues to try to overturn the
2020 election results
trump's unwillingness to concede the
election has now entered historic
territory no major party candidate has
gone as long after election day without
conceding as trump
in modern american history he has now
waited even longer than al gore did
in the year 2000 to put aside partisan
differences and admit defeat
germany is to go into a hard lockdown
over the christmas period as the number
of deaths and infections from the
coronavirus reaches record levels
non-essential shots will close across
the country from wednesday as will
schools with children to be cared for at
home
wherever possible chancellor angela
merkel blamed christmas shopping for a
considerable rise in social contacts
the latest figure shows 20 200 more
infections and a further 321
deaths the new lockdown will run from
the 16th of december to january the 10th
announcing the move after meeting
leaders of the country's 16 states
merkel said
there was an urgent need to take action
restaurants bars and leisure centres
have already been closed since november
and some areas of the country had
imposed their own lockdowns
under the new national lockdown
essential shops such as those selling
food will stay open as can banks
also outlet selling christmas trees can
continue trading
the u.s is gearing up for the rollout of
the pfizer bion tech covid 19
vaccination
after it received emergency use
authorization from the food and drug
administration on friday
u.s army general gustav perner said it
will be delivered to around 145
locations across the country from monday
followed by the remaining 636 delivery
locations on tuesday and wednesday
four soldiers from azerbaijan have been
killed in clashes
in the disputed nagorno-karabakh region
azerbaijan's defense ministry says the
reports come
only weeks after a six-week war over the
territory which
ended when azerbaijan and armenia signed
a ceasefire
armenia meanwhile said six of its own
troops were wounded in what it called an
azerbaijani military offensive
nangorno karabakh has long been a
trigger for violence between the two
the region is recognized as part of
azerbaijan but has been run by ethnic
armenians since 1994 after the two
countries fought a war
over the territory which left thousands
dead a russian brokered truce failed to
bring about lasting peace and the area
has been prone to intermittent clashes
ever since a man was taken into custody
after he climbed onto the wing of an
alaska airlines plane at the las vegas
airport on saturday
flight 1367 from las vegas to portland
was preparing for takeoff from mccarran
international airport
when the pilot noticed a person coming
towards the aircraft and notified the
control tower
las vegas metropolitan police department
and airport officials took the man
into custody the man had hopped a
perimeter fence and was observed
by airport staff from around 1 40 pm
video shot by a passenger shows the man
sitting and walking on the wing he then
removes his socks and shoes before
trying to climb the boeing 737's winglet
the upturned end of the planes as police
officers approach the man he slides down
the winglet and falls onto the tarmac
below
and finally organizers of the bad sex in
fiction award have called off this
year's ceremony saying
that people have suffered enough in
2020. set up in 1993 by the literary
review
the annual prize honors the most
outstandingly awful scene of sexual
description in an otherwise good novel
but as the world remains in the grip of
the covert 19 pandemic it was
felt that an award this year would be
one step too
far previous winners who are all nearly
men
include morrissey tom wolf charles corin
a.a jill
and melvin bragg and as much as sputnik
news would like to feature their
award-winning work
it's all perhaps just a bit too risque
for a family audience
or maybe not because references to a
bulbous
situation can be found in morrissey's
work and the repetition of slither
slithered slither
from wolf have also been involved a
spokesperson for the literary review
said with lockdown regulations giving
rise to all manner of novel sexual
practices
the judges anticipate a rash of entries
next
year authors are reminded that cyber sex
and other forms of home
entertainment fall within the purview of
this
award so there we go listeners and
viewers maybe that's a bit of a
challenge
for the budding novelists out there but
that is the latest
here on sputnik news i'm jamie lowe
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
now the polls going well one year on how
has boris johnson done
a poorly 58
b middling 27
see well still at 15 1605 votes in
so far you've got about 45 minutes
to cast your vote on my twitter feed
now up next is the undisputed
heavyweight champion
of rtuk our intrepid
analyst commentator program maker the
very best
that we have to offer afsin rattancy
joins me now afsan thank you very much
for
taking time out uh i see you're ready
christmas and your house is looking uh
beautiful
uh let me uh introduce the subject
that i want to talk to you about people
like you and me
uh knew right from the beginning that
the dirty war
we've just been talking about the dirty
war in ireland
uh but the dirty war in syria was one
in which the british government was up
to its
neck in the foul excrescences
of dirty wars we were involved in
backing the world's worst people
al-qaeda even isis and the rest of the
alphabet soup of islamist fanaticism
seeking to tear down the secular
character
of the syrian arab republic seeking to
hoist the black flags of islamist
fanaticism
on damascus buildings we knew
because we'd seen it in other parts of
the world principally
iraq the character of these people
and whether or not we loved or didn't
love the government in damascus
we took the view that it could not
possibly be
in the interests of either the people of
syria
or the wider world for these head
chopping
heart-eating fanatics to come to power
anywhere and to the contrary we ought to
unite with everyone who was willing to
do so
to crush these people on the battlefield
and in the battle of ideas that was our
view we knew it
but we then began to get chapter
and verse didn't we and the chapter and
verse that we got
were around issues like the fake
chemical weapons attack on
douma which led to a blizzard
of cruise missiles worth billions of
dollars raining down
on syria in retaliation for something
that
never happened and we saw the chapter
and verse even more clearly
in this phenomena called the white
helmets take up the story from there
tell us about the white helmets and
about what we know now that we might not
have known before
well i should say in the past few
minutes syrian authorities are claiming
they found a whole new cache
of purportedly foreign weaponry in that
in that terrible war that displaced
wounded or killed
so many millions of people and as you
remind us
britain of course bombed syria on
information about an alleged chemical
attack there really is a relationship
actually between your last interview
about uh the alleged state collusion and
the assassinations of a civil rights
lawyer i remember when
john and uh geraldine finukin the
son and widow of the irish civil rights
lawyer came into going underground
they said you know prime minister david
cameron said i've tried my
best i've really tried uh to find the
truth but
there are dark forces out there pointing
out the window
at downing street you know we don't have
that information
about the white helmets yet uh as the
syrian civil war
well as they try the syrian authorities
as other outside forces
try and help syria to uh uh stop uh
stop turning into an isis al-qaeda
capital
uh to continue to do that to this day we
don't know that
because the propaganda never seems to
have been
stopped i mean i know you're covering it
here if you
tune in on the uh state mandated uh
bbc the the famous british organization
that uh
old people uh have to pay for a license
to
listen to on there on their radio uh
on their radio channels they have a
15-part series
on the white helmets and the uh the the
eminor's grease behind the white helmets
james measurer uh
not to be confused with the the famous
dad's army actor as
i know you mentioned dad's army so much
on roads uh who died mysteriously in
istanbul the white helmets are allegedly
a terrorist organization
uh with links to al-qaeda and isis daesh
and they are bankrolled by the british
taxpayer the head of it
was ongoing underground rio del sala he
denied all
links to islamist forces he said
they are a humanitarian group but even
the trump administration's homeland
security operation had to
deny access to uh someone linked to the
oscar-nominated film
some would say propaganda film about the
white helmets the white helmets
uh are a humanitarian force
that the uh whilst uh
people like russia and iran who clearly
backed the syrian government
against isis daesh we'd expect them to
call them terrorists because they were
funded by
foreign intelligence services the
foreign office here in london
but the thing is even the bbc's own
syria producer
said about one attack uh i've got the
quote here
after six months of investigations i can
prove without a doubt the duma
hospital scene was staged this is the
duma
chemical attack scene stage i don't know
that syrian bbc producer she's tweets
about the fact she
can't come on interviews like your show
or my show i don't know why george
when are we going to get the truth about
the white helmets well one thing we
do know is that the uh funds which were
plentiful
uh were uh pilfered uh
in the white helmets account uh we know
that uh the aforementioned majorie
was extremely worried to the point of
committing suicide apparently
the scandal that would unfold
when the serious financial
irregularities were
revealed we have plenty of photographs
of the white helmets acting as the
ambulance brigade of these islamist
fanatics attending
beheadings for example and executions
cheering in the streets when
the parades of isis and al-qaeda and the
others were taking place
we know enough don't we uh to conclude
that far from being the kind of people
british taxpayers would be happy
to hand money to they were the kind of
people that you certainly wouldn't want
well running over london bridge with a
knife in their hand
um i'm the only person as far as i know
to have asked the head of the
white helmets directly about the uh the
beheading
you're referring to and uh that was uh
denied
point blank saying that beheading took
place after
they had removed themselves from that
area i also asked about the famous case
of imran dakhnish the
syrian boy covered in dust whose images
decorated the
arguable propaganda on all nato nation
media
as it uh arguably tried to persuade
populations in nato
countries to uh come in to bomb
syria like it had iraq and afghanistan
as regards that the head of the white
helmets rydell
salah immediately said they hadn't taken
the pictures
of the child and he was now being used
as a propaganda weapon but you're right
when you talk about money and the
mysterious money because even
even a parliamentary report says that
the funding
uh was responsible that the projects do
not collectively meet the needs of uk
security
and the groups may carry out human
rights abuses
as it will uh fall go missing i don't
know where it goes missing
we know there are one in three children
in poverty in in britain
this this money will go missing or be
linked to groups that may
carry out human rights abuses now one of
the
things you mentioned earlier is
one of the great mysteries of 2020.
on radio 4 the
normal programming was interrupted
by what can only be called a 15 part
panergyric propaganda offensive
on behalf of these white helmets not
only that
those who had been the
sternest critics of the white helmets
and of the whole operation
to try and destroy the secular syrian
arab republic
were singled out for and these are
people by the way
who most of the listeners on radio 4
would never have heard of whole program
given to a demolition
of someone vanessa billy i refer to
who most almost all of the listeners
had never heard of this was
extraordinary even by the standards
of the bbc wasn't it you're used to
demolitions and character assassinations
yeah but at least people have heard of
me
i'm worth it
vanessa beeley would definitely say
she's worth it i think uh
it is quite amazing that a 15 part
series along with a
6 000 word piece in the uh famously
anti-julian assange
turncoat newspaper the guardian that
continuously corralled for war
and its sister paper the observer
famously of course wanted the iraq war
to happen great supporter of that
it is quite amazing that they would uh
would
carry out this type of character
assassination i should say it was
seymour hirsch the great journalist who
uncovered the milai massacre the
atrocities at abu ghraib
he couldn't get things published about
the white helmets or the
uh alleged chemical attacks that
required the royal air force to bomb
the the sovereign nation of syria so uh
what is going on behind the scenes is
quite quite astounding i i've only
i'm sure not even you've had 15 15 part
series no
trying to exonerate a group that um is
linked to a suspected mi6 agent linked
to terrorists
and linked to the kinds of atrocities
especially in a week i mean this is
going out while at the same time we're
trying to listen to an inquiry about an
ariana grande atrocity we're connected
to the libya
campaign and uh british support for uh
salafist islamists in in libya fighting
gaddafi
i mean uh given that this is going out
right now is
is uh is incredible they're trying to
also exonerate the fiance as far as i
can understand
according to the first episode of james
the measurer the man that died
the suspected mi6 agent who died in
istanbul
she herself was a former diplomat and
linked
to uh suspicious company called inco
strat uh which has been alleged to be
taking
tens of millions of pounds of british
taxpayers money for
for propaganda purposes as part of the
propaganda campaign to
overthrow president assad of syria so i
mean
uh it looks like if anyone listens to
the bbc about these things
and it should be said all media licensed
in this country that wanted britain
at least from watching it to go to war
in syria
they're not going to get the truth
they're going to have to what you me rt
al jazeera hasn't been doing that great
work on it the qatar
funded agency little bits come out
about this there as the trump
administration uh
uh in the dying days of it we've already
heard that
uh the uh special envoy for syria what's
his name
jim jeffries is saying they lied to the
white house to trump about the numbers
of u.s
troops in syria repeatedly over numbers
of years
so it was like this complete secret uh
separate
war with intelligence agencies two
governments really in both countries
don't we
we've got the official public elected
governments
and we've got the continual governments
the governments
that never stand for election but seem
to call the shots
in both countries but what did david
cameron mean about the pap fanookan
killing that there are dark forces out
there i had to ask the
the sun and the bereaved widow i mean
this is like out of a thriller
similarly we now know then that the
white house was being routinely lied to
about
u.s taxpayers money funding the syrian
war and now of course
there's something even more serious than
some bbc arguable garbage to resuscitate
a terror linked group called the white
helmets there is
the restoration of a raytheon contractor
to become head of the pentagon
there is tony blinken someone who
favored a more robust what
what kind of vocabulary do they use i
mean bombing using warplanes
aerial bombardment of civilian cities
he's going to be secretary of state
and then this other guy jake sullivan is
the national security adviser
is biden's first act going to be to bomb
syria because
not only because trump didn't want to
although trump did
did bomb syria it has to be added and uh
and what will
boris johnson do as he finds himself
arguably more
isolated from the european union he'll
take part to
get ready the royal air force and get
ready the u.s air force to bomb syria
it won't end well given that russia iran
china uh i think the whole of the global
south are up to
up to what they're uh what they're
thinking right now
i'd like to wish you a happy new year
but i i don't think i could do so
credibly it's going to be a tumultuous
year but we'll continue
god willing to report on it absent
rotancy thank you very much indeed
for joining us on the mind all talk
shows
now you're uh fully entitled of course
to dispute any or all
of what you've heard this evening here's
the number 02077-982-255
or from the u.s 0 0 1 7 5
7 7 4 4 4 4 8
0. you can dispute it or you can agree
with it of course
and we'll be taking calls uh from 8
30. uh we're inundated with social media
i'm not able to bring you much but
joanne says
joe biden will pardon hunter biden
just like trump is pardoning his corrupt
family
and guy says both sides of u.s politics
and the mainstream media
are controlled by the same people
orchestrated drama for the masses
james says has the u.s had a clean
election
in living memory i mean seriously and
betty
says trump and biden could have made
could have been made in the same factory
stop arguing about the small
peculiarities
the elite are taking over and anyone
reading this
is not included and georgie on the poll
says boris johnson's the worst pm
in living memory but a lot of people
still think he's wonderful i kid you not
i'm having a hard time suggesting
otherwise to workmates and locals
because the media have done a wonderful
job on brainwashing
salt of the earth decent working class
people
nearby and alan says boris johnson
changes his stance
all the time he's prepared to compromise
on just about anything
which is why he achieves nothing at all
much more
where that came from i need to take a 60
second
break you can count them
barnier said in his latest statement
despite the difficulties we face
an agreement is within reach if both
sides are willing to work constructively
if they are willing to copy
sacred blue 60 billion in le toilet
is the maginot line all over again what
shall we do
we have got to get the englanders of
treasure islands back home track
and gets them over paying for our cars
again my
union friends what shall we do
we are running out of options there is
only one thing we can do
what we do best
morning morning european union reversing
morning morning george galloway
and the mother of all talk shows join us
at the college of knowledge where there
are no tuition fees
now this is where i look back at the
seven days in which we are currently
and which in history shaped and probably
for the good and the bad in this week
it was on this day in 1961 that four
scruffs from liverpool signed a
management contract
with brian epstein they were of course
the beatles spinning forward to 1995
this was the day
when riots broke out in brixton london
hundreds of black and white youths took
to the streets of south london
attacking the police ransacking shops
and burning cars
after the death of yet another black man
in police custody
the riots followed a peaceful picket of
the police station
triggered by the death of wayne douglas
aged
26 and in 2001
a group of gunmen broke through tight
security
to attack the parliament building in the
indian capital
new delhi at least 12 people were killed
22 injured in that attack
three men suspected kashmiri militants
were convicted and sentenced to death in
december 2002
for supporting and helping to plan the
attack on parliament
the sentences were commuted this is the
week in 1911 when norwegian
raul the amundsen's exhibition was the
first
to reach the south pole the british
competitor
captain scott was not best pleased he
did go on to reach the poll
five weeks later then died in 1955
labour elected hugh gateska as its new
leader
succeeding clement atlee and in 1995
the leaders of bosnia serbia and croatia
signed the dayton
accord in paris to end more than three
years of bitter conflict
on the 14th of december in 2003
the ousted president of iraq saddam
hussein
was arrested after his capture by
u.s soldiers ladies and gentlemen
we got him the laughingly named u.s
administrator paul bremer
told journalists in baghdad the tyrant
he said is a prisoner the former
president was
executed on the 30th of december 2006
after iraq's highest kangaroo court
rejected
an appeal this is the week on december
in 1939 to be precise that gone with the
wind
the film starring clark gable and vivian
lee premiered
where else atlanta frankly my dears i
don't give a damn
in 1955 johnny cash released folsom
prison blues
it was a slow burner it finally became
billboard song of the year
in 1968 13 years later
i remember this one well it was in 2004
that home secretary david blunkett
resigned
after an email implicated him in using
his position
to grant favors to his former lover
although the idea of david blanket
making love still makes me
shiver it follows the revelation in
august
that he was having an affair with a
married woman
she was kimberly quinn the american
publisher of the
spectator magazine quinn gave birth to a
baby boy
in february 2005. a dna test established
that blanket was not the father he was a
bit of a serial offender he was
again forced to resign in november 2005
after breaking the ministerial code of
conduct
over paid work he took while he was out
of the cabinet
and on december 16th in 1969
mps voted by a big majority for the
permanent abolition
of the death penalty for murder a day
later
on december 17th in 1903 the wright
brothers made the first
motorized aircraft flight the pilot was
orville right
and it took place at kitty hawk south
carolina
on this same december day in 1944
german tanks aircraft and paratroops
crossed the luxembourg and belgium
borders
in a massive counter-offensive which was
called the battle
of the bulge and in 1989
the simpsons created by matt
groening premiered as a full animated
series
with the episode simpsons roasting on an
open fire it's been 30 years of the
simpsons
in 2003 the former school caretaker
ian huntley was found guilty of the
murder
of two ten-year-old storm school girls
holly wells
and jessica chapman he was given two
life
sentences on the 18th of the month in
the british government said it would pay
000 pounds compensation to relatives of
the
13 men killed shot dead by british
paratroopers
on bloody sunday in derry nearly three
years before
thirteen men were killed when british
troops opened fire
on a group of peaceful demonstrators in
the bauxside district
of derry the 42 000 pounds was the total
for everyone killed the relatives did
accept the compensation money
but they continue the fight to this day
and in 1997 a bill giving scotland its
own parliament
for the first time in three centuries
was unveiled in glasgow
scottish secretary donald jr revealed
his blueprint for the future of scottish
politics
and called on the house of lords not to
delay
or disrupt its passage into law they
didn't
the scotland act 1998 was finally
introduced and elections to the scottish
assembly were held in may of 1999.
juror became scotland's first minister
and later the same month
the scottish parliament met for the
first time
a year ago in 2019 the us house of
representatives voted to
impeach president donald trump for abuse
of power
and obstruction of congress that didn't
work
and on the 19th of december in our
history it's a day that has some
resonance it was in 1783
that william pitt the younger became the
youngest
ever british prime minister at the age
of
24. and
in 1971 stanley kubrick's x-rated film a
clockwork orange
based on the book by anthony burgess and
directed by stanley kubrick
premiered in 1984 the
deal to return the british colony of
hong kong to china
in 1997 was signed chris
patton the last governor of hong kong or
fat pang as he was known locally
introduced so-called democratic reforms
in 1992 which the chinese government
opposed the ramifications of that
continue
to this day and no doubt beyond that
was the week that was let's take some
calls
simon in london is first up go ahead
simon
how you doing george okay oh good thanks
that's good that's good
listen i've always believed and always
will believe that the environmental
movement is covertly
one of the most bigoted most sweetest
scientific the most racist
most corrupt organizations the entire
world behind every
thunderbird behind every alcohol behind
every jaw bite and behind everybody's
constant tony blair
barack obama and behind every idiot that
attends the paris climate accord and
enjoy lobster thermador dinner
there's a rather dark and sadistic
intention to keep the poor poorer
and the rich richer all you need to do
is see how their rules and regulations
kept the poor
climate change and it's man-made when in
actual fact there's plenty of evidence
to suggest
otherwise and i won't mention the fact
that far-left journalists like george
monbiot though
thought that a real political matter
like the false imprisonment of julian
assange who let's face it revealed the
crimes behind
the extraction of the very oil that they
claimed to be against
was less important than the
environmental woman uh the other thing i
just wanted to
elaborate on uh is the uh the terrific
documentary i watched a couple of weeks
ago the great global warming swindle
which
suggested the environmental movement was
primarily fueled
in the 1980s by margaret thatcher to
kill the mining industry
her stance was to throw money at the
researchers and scientists and literally
say
there's the money on the table let's get
some results for anti-fossil fuel um
stance and that's exactly what they got
and since then the political
politicized science behind environmental
because
environmentalism has become a
multi-million dollar industry something
that newspapers and editors
and new favorites and magazine editors
rarely question anyone who does
question is brandon heretic so my
question to you is very simple
what do you think of this week's
ridiculous virtual climate conference
when boris johnson claimed that the uk
needed to cut direct funding for fossil
fuel developments around the world
without his daddy and saudi arabia being
present do you really think that these
environmental nut jobs actually believe
that this will mean that british troops
will be pulled out of afghanistan and
iraq
and other countries and will stop
selling weapons to saudi arabia for
access to oil
well i i i don't know anything about the
virtual conference i've been rather busy
with the real world
on the here and now issues you've
you've made a hundred points there some
of them
powerfully and some of them correctly
the only one i have time to take issue
with is your description of george
monbio
as a far-left journalist he's a liberal
and that's all he is and he
shows demonstrates all the time his
liberal character never confuse
liberalism with the left that's all i've
got time to say
jalau is in manchester go ahead jalau
oh george how are you good thanks
good god i spoke to you regarding juan
guerdos being uh
a potential for the us
presidency yeah i do remember he's about
to be ditched
rightfully so so what's going on it'll
be a bit embarrassing for the british
who
just uh rededicated themselves to him uh
in a foreign office statement from the
foreign secretary
just this week jesus he should have
waited for the sunday papers
it should have um the point i want to
make is
if gary kushner was to walk into a room
and shake her hand would you make sure
all five fingers are there
yes i would and i don't shake uh
people's hands nowadays unfortunately i
just uh bump elbows or
at the most uh bump fists but jared
kushner is
a particularly repulsive individual to
me
uh and if there is going to be trumpism
after
trump i earnestly hope that he is not
the
chosen one uh the uh
he may well be his wife is perhaps
slightly
more likely or maybe donald trump jr
would be they wouldn't have to change
the posters
then but that trumpism after trump will
continue maybe even
with donald trump i'm absolutely sure
jalal thanks
for the call i need to take a break to
change my batteries you didn't know
that i was battery operated did you be
right back
radio sputnik
we are above all the latest developments
and we don't
take any sides radio sputnik
telling the untold
the airwaves this savannah
is a rigid dictomy of fact
and fiction as fisher says the
twittersphere where the slightest
misjudgment can spell
being cancelled
one species rules over the airwaves
through its ability to adapt and survive
in even the harshest environments
the george getaway
[Music]
the top cat in these parts it is mostly
active on sunday evenings in britain
and mid-afternoon in the united states
it's seldom roars during the day
most notable for its wide variety of
address
it protects these parts from the
mainstream media
you can catch this fine specimen on the
mother
of all talk shows
don't pick a fight with it they've been
known to bite
back
you're listening to radio sputnik
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
i was brilliant simon i must say you're
outdoing yourself with these
jingles how wonderful they are the polls
still running
i think for about another five minutes
or so one year on how has boris johnson
done
how's it been for you poorly 58
middling 27 well
15 no calls yet from the 15
percent that's a pity actually now uh dr
ranjit braar is the most medic
consultant physician and surgeon
on the coronavirus welcome back dr
ranjit
thanks george good to be with you just
uh time for a quick update
if you will uh how are the numbers
uh now as we approach christmas when
it's going to be
i promise you a free for all are they
rising how alarmingly
and what's the latest on the vaccine
thanks george so very briefly in the
world um the pandemic continues to surge
uh thanksgiving on top of everything
else in america
means that they have had their worst
week on record
similarly in canada similarly across
much of europe and it looks like
lots of places are going into a harder
lockdown interestingly and there's no
satisfaction in saying this but it's a
it's a point to note given the previous
uh debate that we've had
uh sweden is having an extremely tough
time and they have said that uh
in the south of their country around the
capital they essentially have reached
capacity of their health system they've
reached capacity
of their intensive care and they're
actually appealing to their fellow
scandinavian countries for
assistance with record numbers of health
professionals actually leaving
under the stress of of the of the
numbers of admissions to hospitals so
something something to note this this is
not over and i'm afraid that the simple
strategy of herd immunity uh on its own
um is proving increasingly everywhere
and in all cases to be
a failure in the world we have seen now
72 and a half million cases united
states 16.6 million india
close to 10 million brazil close to 7
million in the uk we're coming up to the
2 million mark
and the official record now says that we
had 64 000
deaths uh if you look we've definitely
gone back into the territory of excess
mortality but those figures haven't
really been updated i suspect the figure
is much closer to
80 90 or even 100 000 so very
significant numbers um certainly 0.1
to the population so a thousand in every
million
of our population have succumbed to the
pandemic and whereas the
lockdown such as it was slightly
haphazard slightly chaotic
slightly delayed had a suppressant
effect on the number of
cases that we saw in britain uh it's
really just held steady and there are
signs now that as it we've come out of
lockdown
uh or or the equivalent thereof wasn't
really like our first lockdown
um we had reservations about it that we
discussed that the numbers are
increasing again particularly in london
uh the south east
uh uh kent and and essex in particularly
badly hit and it does seem that
if you drill down into those figures
again it's the uh poorest
uh sections of the working class who
proved
unable to isolate in newham in the north
of
uh and east of london in kent people who
are working in
the service sector people who are
working in health people who just simply
couldn't afford to stop working if they
were going to keep their heads above
water economically speaking these are
the people it seems who have been
driving infections so while rates are
down in the northwest there are areas
which are in tier three in london that
remains tier two
we seem to be driving um the pandemic
currently so that we've seen a large
number of deaths perhaps uh over 3000
deaths in the last week in the united
kingdom
hospitalizations hospital occupied beds
with patients with coved
remains 14 and a half thousand so not
great deal down from the around 16 000
at the peak prior to the lockdown
and cases uh also worryingly
now showing an increase so as well as
the pre pandemic the highest levels we
saw were around the 26 000 a day
and those came down to about 16 000 a
day immediately
uh at the end of the of the lockdown uh
we are again
seeing 21 000 test proven positive
cases a day george so every sign um
that we really just mildly applied the
break
but i'm afraid it seems to be
accelerating again within the country
and uh so sweden wasn't the valhalla
claimed uh by those who claimed it
obviously we take no satisfaction uh
from that
equally those who have been locking down
uh
haven't uh haven't killed the thing off
either
no indeed and so you really see i mean
the very interesting uh article i read
in the lancet it's actually a couple of
weeks old when i read it
uh in which they very publicly and i've
seen
a couple of um articles in the in the
mainstream press following this they've
actually kind of admitted
that china has beaten the virus and they
looked at the reasons why it was
interesting it was polish commentators
polish health commentators who said
and they quoted in this lancet article
that china has an ingrained
part of their culture uh which is to
respect
the greater good and that's a government
level and population level
they take respiratory infections
seriously they recently had the sars
outbreak and they realize what
what it what havoc it can wreak they
were prepared to
comply with non-pharmacological health
care
measures just as we were saying
throughout you know march april may when
we were discussing this george
um this is now right widely you know
recognized and their
great reward has been that they still
have not really seen any more than 90
000 cases they essentially have wiped
coronavirus out amongst their enormous
population
so you know what really shows you is um
you don't have that high print
again their words the hyper
individualistic anti-vaxx
uh so-called freedom of the individual
movement which in the end doesn't result
in freedom
of the individual freedom really stems
from the recognition of necessity
there's no freedom and death
there's no freedom and illness freedom
comes from the taking the necessary
measures to protect your population and
through protecting your population
protecting the economy which after all
should serve the population georgia amen
very well said uh
one bit of good news uh that i saw this
week at least i thought so
uh oxford university are now you may say
belatedly
collaborating with russia and the makers
of the sputnik 5
vaccine to perhaps synthesize their two
products
uh to make it more efficacious
yeah i found that very interesting as
well i don't know if you so there was an
interesting side story i don't think
we've
discussed it on on the um the the oxford
astrazeneca virus sarah gilbert is a
professor there
uh who's been much in the in the media
who's been in charge of developing this
vaccine
but they obviously had a a large trial
they've actually they haven't published
the results of their trial but they are
actually that's not true i think they
have published the results of their
trial
um and they have submitted the their
trial now
um to uh the mrha the medicine and
healthcare regulatory authority then
they are seeking approval for their
vaccine
but when they published it uh there was
a funny um
disparity between their results so their
main protocol
giving a full dose of the vaccine
followed by a second full versus vaccine
i think three weeks later
uh in their case um had a around a 60
efficacy or just over um but then there
was a subset of individuals who had a
very low dose
of the fur or half half the dose and it
was essentially a mistake
in their trial protocol in a subset of
something like 1500 patients
who received a low dose and then a full
dose and and strangely and they didn't
understand why
um they had a far higher efficacy of
over 90 percent
in their vaccine and very quickly the
the sputnik team when they offered their
assistance they said they knew why that
was and the sputnik vaccine
you remember we discussed essentially
it's the same kind of vaccine it's an
adenovirus it's a cold virus
vector a way of introducing the rna
into into the immune system so they use
a cold virus to do it but the
the russians fighting vaccine uses two
different cold viruses because you can
become
immune to the cold virus and therefore
when you give a second dose it doesn't
it doesn't really have the same effect
your immune system doesn't see that rna
it simply removes the cold virus
so it doesn't give that second boost uh
and the the the sputnik team
uh pointed this out actually to the
asparagus the oxford team
uh straight away when they published
their results they said this is because
they're using one single atom of
virus vector and so essentially to me
what it means if they're collaborating
is it will be a way of
the russian vaccine getting much wider
circulation in countries which will only
buy
um the the kind of main pharmaceutical
giant's
vaccines but really it amounts to using
the two
different vectors in the two different
doses so really it's no different from
just using the sputnik vaccine alone
which will be equally efficacious i
suspect this trial is just starting
they'll use one dose of the uh of the of
the the sparkling vaccine one dose of
the astrologer and that will essentially
mean
they've reproduced you know the the two
differing doses of the sputnik so
it's good that they're they're doing
that i'm glad it'd be that that
cooperation it will mean that a large
number of people in the world probably
will have access to an effective
vaccine that otherwise may not have done
so i'm i'm i'm happy about it george
dr one caller on the line if you can
spare us the time
timothy in massachusetts about the
vaccine timothy go ahead
yes george thank you for taking my call
welcome dr b
is on the line too yes dr broad two
questions for you please does
the vaccine stop the transmission of the
coven 19
and the second question would be would
the recipient of the vaccine
become an asymptomatic carrier thank you
doctor
thank you thanks very much timothy
so if we think about vaccines in general
um
then the fact that so essentially what a
vaccine does is it exposes your immune
system
in advance are you still there george
yes very much so
sorry i i lost you sorry um so
essentially what the vaccine does is it
primes your immune system
to recognize the infection prior to
receiving the infection so that when you
meet the infection your
immune system rapidly clears the virus
or the
or the particles which you're being
immune immunized from the body so
there'll be a time at which you
have contact with an environmentally
present uh
uh agent in this case the covered
vaccine
it's very likely that you will be able
to clear that and won't become an
active uh agent of transition that is
likely
you know but that the bottom line is
these relatively small trials they're
big trials in themselves but they're
small compared to the numbers of cases
we're talking about the number of doses
that will be given out
weren't powered to ascertain that they
weren't designed to ascertain that and
so there's no way that anyone will be
able to say
definitely yes what they've been powered
to do is to essentially reduce the
incidence of
infection to reduce the incense of
severe infection to reduce the incidence
not even of death actually in most
instances because those death events
will be too infrequent within the kind
of
study population they looked at so the
answer is no one can give that
result because there simply haven't been
large enough numbers
of the vaccine given but our whole
experience of immunology in a
vaccinology
suggests that that would be the case
we're likely
to stop being an asymptomatic carrot
we're likely to stop being
a vector of transmission but
you know those answers are not yet fully
known timothy last word to you
uh george a pleasure your show's great
and uh thank you for taking my call and
thank you doctor for uh
your answer you're a gentleman thank you
very much indeed dr br
thank you uh indeed for a truncated
uh spot this evening just because of the
pressure
of events thank you indeed uh the poll
is closing 1839 votes are
in and the overwhelming
majority uh 59 percent of you
say that boris johnson has done poorly
middling
26 that's down one 15 percent of you
still say
boris johnson has done well so more than
two to one
uh between uh poorly and middling
and a very comfortable majority against
boris johnson however
as you'll discover when i talked to the
diane
uh of cyphologists and political
scientists
professor sir john curtis that feeling
does not actually
translate in voting intentions
the labor leader keith starmer
of whom it was predicted in advance
labor would be 20 points ahead
of this failing boris johnson
continues to trail boris
johnson some more comments
sarah says we've had an unprecedented
year and i
honestly don't see anyone getting it
much better
this past year has seen the pm and his
government
thinking on their feet firefighting
with little evidence of what would work
best and having to change continually
as evidence became clear ah was that
what they were doing sarah
john says we will see if bojo has a
backbone
in the next few weeks i don't think he
has any moral courage
and will cave in to the eu but that
betrayal will be his short
historical legacy as well as his swan
song and david
says i actually wonder who could have
done better
with him getting covered badly a new
baby
dealing with brexit and a global
pandemic but i'm sure everyone will tell
me
that jeremy would have walked it and
scott says boris doesn't need to be
a popular pm he isn't scared there is no
credible opposition the working class
can believe in
labor chose walk and they've gone broke
good line that scott and phil says could
anyone have done any better
given all pardon me that's happened
since january if so
who and how and sam says
you have to give rt credit for having
people like galloway hedges
ventura richard wolff and others they
are commentators that the mainstream
american corporate media
won't dare to have on true enough sam
let's take a call from mike in scotland
go ahead mike
yeah well i do i think boris has done a
brilliant job
no but has he done a job yeah he has
actually
and i think what's really sort of like
pissed people off
that are brexiteers is the backing of
the uk
for boris no one's backing him
the guy's the guy's charging over the
hill on his own
he's looking behind him and there's
nobody there
what about his cabinet are you not
impressed by them
no i'm not actually i don't think that
the cabinet that boris has got is the
cabinet that
boris wants what what he can
do he appoints the cabinet oh yeah but i
think he's got a poor
lot to choose from he's probably got the
best lot to choose from
out of all the political parties but
even then i think politicians need to
have
no qualifications to have a job these
days other than
some fake lies to win at the ballot box
well he spent the best part of a hundred
billion pounds of your money
mike do you think he's spent it well um
possibly i think i'm maybe to the spent
a better
but it's like the
oh mike are you there i'm still here
yeah you said he could have possibly
spent it better
but well yeah but the conservatives
always get the blame that all they do is
lace the pockets of their friends and
mates from public high schools
and do they no i don't think they do
what do we want to give it to do we want
to give that money to
people with no background no that's
exactly what we did do
we gave billions to people we gave
billions
mike we're talking about a government
that gave a ferry contract to a company
with no ferries
was boris didn't get me started on
scotland
no i'm not no i'm not talking about that
i'm talking about the
uh contract to to a company
in the south coast of england which had
no ferries i don't know the details of
that oh well you're not a regular
listener
okay let me ask you another question
mike um
do you think he's going to cave in
to the eu do you think that's what this
postponement means
do i think he is going to give it i
think he probably is
to a degree i hope he doesn't
but i think he might give something to
appease
the ramonas so uh
you you'd give him what uh uh poorly
middling or well well no
i i said he's well done but i think he
lacks the backing
of the uk public you know i mean
he's out there on his own and nobody's
backing him
it's a pretty tough place to be and i
think
because of that he's doing all right
following in the footsteps of theresa
may
my god it's just like the evening
that's a pretty low bar though uh is he
churchill
is he churchill he was our prime
minister
that's how lower barriers got i know i
know
i'm agreeing with you i'm agreeing with
you mike
uh she only just won a general election
uh the um she threw away the big
majority that she had and traded it in
for a very narrow one which donna was
that a mistake was that a mistake
uh-huh it was um now lastly
you're in scotland do you think the uh
do you think the
tory government under boris are letting
the snp away with murder
yes well you can vote on the next poll
which is
this thanks for that mike are the snp
getting away with murder
a yes 83 percent b
no nine percent c couldn't care less
eight percent you can vote now right now
on my twitter feed let's get the news
with jamie lowe
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news the final deadline
in talks between the united kingdom and
the european union turned out not to be
once more in a joint statement british
prime minister boris johnson
and european commission president ursula
vonda lyon said it was responsible
at this point to go the extra mile the
pair discussed major unresolved topics
during their call
the two sides had said that sunday was
to be the deadline for a decision on
whether to continue with talks with the
uk set to leave the eu rules
at the end of the month the leaders
agreed to tell negotiators to carry on
talks in brussels to quote
see whether an agreement can even at
this late stage
be reached they did not say how long
these latest talks would continue but
the ultimate deadline is the 31st of
december
and time must be allowed for the uk and
european parliaments to vote on any deal
that emerges before then vondale said
sunday's call with johnson had been
quote constructive
and useful but johnson repeated his
warning from earlier in the week that a
no deal scenario was most likely the uk
and eu have been carrying out
negotiations for a post-brexit trade
deal since
march and are attempting to secure one
before the so-called transition period
end on the 31st of december when two
sides would move to trading on world
trade organization rules
without a trade deal tariffs which are
charges on goods being bought and sold
between the two sides could be
introduced
and in turn prices on certain products
may go up
thousands of donald trump supporters
alleging electoral fraud converged on
several u.s cities and towns on saturday
and there were isolated scuffles with
counter demonstrators
in washington dc more than 20 people
were arrested and four people were
stabbed police said
trump lost the november third election
to joe biden but
is yet to concede the electoral college
the system which elects u.s presidents
is due to endorse mr biden's victory
tomorrow
biden won 306 votes to mr trump's 232 in
the electoral college
and gained over 7 million more votes
than his republican rival in the popular
vote
however trump shows no signs of
acknowledging reality as he continues to
try to overturn the 2020 election
results
trump's unwillingness to concede the
election has now entered historic
territory
no major party candidate has gone as
long after election day without
conceding
as trump in modern american history he
has now waited even longer than al gore
did in the year 2000 to put aside
partisan differences
and admit defeat germany is to go into a
hard lockdown over the christmas period
as the number of deaths and infections
from the coronavirus reaches record
levels
non-essential shops will close across
the country from wednesday
as will schools with children to be
cared for at home
wherever possible chancellor angela
merkel blamed christmas shopping for a
considerable rise in social contacts
the latest figure shows 20 200 more
infections and a further 321 deaths
the new lockdown will run from the 16th
of december to january the 10th
announcing the move after meeting
leaders of the country's 16 states
merkel said there was an urgent need to
take action
restaurants bars and leisure centres
have already been closed since november
and some areas of the country had
imposed their own lockdowns
under the new national lockdown
essential shops such as those selling
food will stay open as can banks
also outlet selling christmas trees can
continue
trading the u.s is gearing up for the
rollout of the pfizer biontech covid19
vaccination after it received emergency
use authorization from the food and drug
administration on friday
u.s army general gustav perner said it
will be delivered to around 145
locations across the country from monday
followed by the remaining 636 delivery
locations on tuesday and wednesday
four soldiers from azerbaijan have been
killed in clashes in the disputed
nagorno-karabakh region
azerbaijan's defense ministry says the
reports come
only weeks after a six-week war over the
territory which
ended when azerbaijan and armenia signed
a ceasefire
armenia meanwhile said six of its own
troops were wounded in what it called an
azerbaijani military offensive
nangorno karabakh has long been a
trigger for violence between the two
the region is recognized as part of
azerbaijan but has been run by ethnic
armenians since 1994 after the two
countries fought a war
over the territory which left thousands
dead a russian brokered truce failed to
bring about lasting peace and the area
has been prone to intermittent clashes
ever since
a man was taken into custody after he
climbed onto the wing of an alaska
airlines plane at the las vegas airport
on saturday
flight 1367 from las vegas to portland
was preparing for takeoff from mccarran
international airport
when the pilot noticed a person coming
towards the aircraft and notified the
control tower
las vegas metropolitan police department
and airport officials took the man
into custody the man had hopped a
perimeter fence and was observed by
airport staff from around 1
40 pm video shot by a passenger shows
the man sitting and walking on the wing
he then removes his socks and shoes
before trying to climb the boeing 737's
winglet
the upturned end of the plane as police
officers approach
the man he slides down the winglet and
falls onto the tarmac below
and finally organizers of the bad sex in
fiction award have called off this
year's ceremony saying
that people have suffered enough in
2020. set up in 1993 by the literary
review
the annual prize honors the most
outstandingly awful scene of sexual
description in an
otherwise good novel but as the world
remains in the grip of the covert 19
pandemic it was felt that an award
this year would be one step too far
previous winners who are all
nearly men include morrissey tom wolf
giles corin
a.a jill and melvin bragg and as much as
sputnik news would like to feature their
award-winning
work it's all perhaps just a bit too
risque
for a family audience or maybe not
because references to a bulbous
situation
can be found in morrissey's work and the
repetition
of slither slithered slither from wolf
have also been
involved a spokesperson for the literary
review said with lockdown regulations
giving rise to all manner of novel
sexual practices
the judges anticipate a rash of entries
next
year authors are reminded that cyber sex
and other forms of home
entertainment fall within the purview of
this
award so there we go listeners and
viewers maybe that's a bit of a
challenge for the budding novelists out
there but that is the latest
here on sputnik news i'm jamie lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
professor sir john curtis of strathclyde
university is
widely regarded accepted as the
premier political scientist in the land
the prince of
psyphology were the knight of the realm
of
sophology and he joins me now and i'm
grateful to you sir john
let me cut to the chase boris johnson is
widely regarded
certainly amongst this audience as
having done
a pretty poor job in the last 12 months
and yet he's still ahead in the polls
how so
well he's just about ahead in the polls
short answer of course is that in many
respects we are still talking about
an electorate that is divided over
brexit
and for so long as boris johnson seems
to be
capable of delivering the brexit that
many a lead voter
wants um then certainly those voters are
not inclined to switch labour party some
of them having truth in the wake of
disappointment with honey and
coronavirus they're kind of sitting on
their hands and saying
not quite sure i know what i would do in
future um but still the case
you know two-thirds of these to those
people who voted leave back in 2016
uh are still inclined to vote for the
concerns because the concerns of course
are the party
that uh somehow or another are going to
deliver the brexit that they voted for
i mean not many governments have done
well uh in the
era of the coronavirus uh and only 15
of my audience thought that boris
johnson had done well what do your
numbers
tell you about how people regard the
handling of the coronavirus the
expenditure the
vast sums of money to little effect
yeah the answer is that boris johnson
does not get a very good press
i mean somewhere around a quarter to
30 percent currently feel that he's been
hunting the coronavirus well
uh he comes out much worse of course
than nicola sturgeon the scottish first
minister
and mark drakeford the welsh first
neither of whom in terms of you know the
actual outcomes
have necessarily done particularly
better than boris johnson but
it's boris johnson's ability to handle
the coronavirus
to seem to be able to know what he's
doing
to be able to communicate effectively
with the electorate
and this has all been found pretty badly
wanting
and found pretty badly wanting really
ever since may may was the crucial month
that under boris johnson's popularity
suffice coronavirus is concerned
and two things one is there was his
first speech
that television broadcast the middle of
may
um when he said the lockdown was being
eased but
left a lot of confused messages
including people saying well does that
mean i meant to go to work tomorrow so
that didn't help and secondly of course
the dominant cummings affair which just
did
the government's uh handling of the
coronavirus in the eyes of the
electorate
uh no good at all so i mean the trouble
is that
you know boris johnson is a politician
for sunny upland times
he's not a politician for when things
are difficult
he's not necessarily a politician for
making difficult decisions
and he's not a politician who gives the
impression of being in charge of the
detail
uh these are all fairly important
weaknesses uh when you're having a
pandemic and
the contrast particularly with nick
sturgeon who
sounds as though she knows what she's
doing is across the detail
doesn't make uh doesn't make claims
above and beyond what she's able to
deliver for the most part
and frankly is simply willing to admit
mistakes in the way that
uh boris johnson finds very very
difficult all these things basically
undermine
boris johnson's evaluation as a highly
pandemic but the point is that
yes this has cost the conservative
support but
it's not it's not it's only basically
brought them to roughly even stevens
with labor
because of course nobody's problem in
the last nine months is that
while it has chipped away
at the government's handling of
coronavirus
um if anybody wants to know what the
liberal party thinks under kirstama
the moment very very difficult to tell
and there is in truth a limit to how far
you can expect to win the electorate
back
simply by chevying the government um
and indeed you know even this week when
the labour party finally
was willing to talk about brexit well of
course boris johnson is perfectly well
aware the labour party is not very happy
about what he should do about brexit
whether it should vote for a deal or not
if a deal does indeed transpire so uh
because there isn't very clear united
law party position on brexit
its attacks on the prime minister even
on this issue are inclined to rather
fall flat
now we'll come back to uh nicola
sturgeon uh
and i profoundly disagree with you on
the points that you made there
but let's deal with brexit first i i
i expected to be talking to you tonight
about the brexit deal
there is no brexit deal uh somebody on
social media just said to me that we
elected boris johnson
thinking he was a big hitter but he's
turned out to be a big wet lettuce
uh how damaging to him do you think
it is uh that uh this much
hyped deadline set by him
has come and gone like all the deadlines
before it
well i don't think they're missing the
deadlines is what's going to matter two
things now really matter one is
in the end is there a deal or is there
no deal
um and if there is a deal can the prime
minister
persuade lee voters that he's delivered
what they want
as opposed to making an unacceptable
compromise um and the deal what he faces
is that it's only a minority of league
voters
who would prefer to leave without a deal
no more than around one in three of them
but well over half of lead voters say
but uh but we shouldn't make too many
compromises
in order to get one and that in a sense
is the cleft stick that he's that he's
caught in
so that's part one what what eventually
transpires now if he goes for no deal i
mean
there is no doubt he's taking quite a
considerable risk
because in any event the next part of
the story will be
what happens after the first of germany
to what extent
if at all are the uk supply chains
indifferently are there uh
empty shelves in some of the
supermarkets perhaps particularly
importantly are there any difficulties
in getting crucial medicines into the uk
or not
and of course if it does happen who gets
the blame um but in a sense it's really
only going to be next year when actually
the uk is finally out of the single
market that
whatever is going to be the reality of
brexit begins to kick in
and it's only at that point i think we
will discover whether or not
particularly lead voters go well
yeah that's fine that's what i voted for
whether they go
hang on this is not going quite so well
as we thought and
which of these transfers we don't know
but in a sense
missing deadlines you know frankly who
cares
it's what happens at the end whether or
not
boris johnson can sell it and then
irrespective where the deal is no deal
what happens after the 1st of january
do things turn out well or badly and if
they turn out badly
can boris johnson put the blame on the
eu or not do you think that his position
as leader of the conservative party
would be
imperiled by being seen to have
considered too much it won't
help but i think the truth is the thing
that would above
all what would damage him is that if
um go going back to that tomorrow's
painting if indeed
now whatever decision he makes brexit
goes
badly that is that there is more
disruption
than people were anticipating it goes on
for longer than people are anticipating
we have cues of people of of lorries uh
hanging up
across dover we have people coming onto
the media saying
i cannot get my crucial medicine that
controls my heart rhythm or whatever
because the difficulty that he faces is
that i mean there's certainly
concern inside the conservative party
just simply about
the competence with which he's handled
the pandemic
now of course in part that's a debate
about whether or not he's been
according to the views of some mps to
beholden to his scientists
and in the views of other mps perhaps
not taking enough notice of them but
certainly that for some tory mps as it
were almost irrespective when they stand
on the brexit uh
has led to some no discussion in quiet
corners about what actually is he really
up to the job
if now on brexit the charge would be
actually incompetence the government
wasn't ready to deal with
um the new arrangement with with the eu
and first of january and as a result
the supply chains are messed up etc etc
then that charge of incompetence will as
it won't get another leg to it
and that and if in if i did in the wake
of that
we do that get up the concerns begin to
fall behind in the polls for
any great length of time then yes you
know there may well be questions because
tory mps will be asking themselves well
hang on maybe indeed this is
not somebody somebody who yes can
make a good speech uh create a good
laugh
and sometimes um uh make uh
come up with very strong rhetorical
lines but maybe who at the end of the
day
is not necessarily somebody who's
particularly good at doing the job but
he said we're not at that point yet
but certainly some of that mumbling is
going on and there will be
more concern about that effects it goes
badly now sir john you
conceded earlier that actually
nicola sturgeon has not in terms of
outcomes done
any better than boris johnson
but the perception particularly in
london
less so i think in scotland is that she
has
uh oh very much very much so in scotland
george um
her numbers have come down a bit we're
still talking about
uh you know high 60s percent of people
saying they're satisfied with hatching
on the pandemic
uh more than twice the figure for boris
johnson even across the uk as a whole
there is an enormous gap of perception
well well if
then if so uh that in a sense
makes my point uh better uh
someone who 60 of the people think has
done a good job
but you can see that she has not done a
better job than
boris johnson who's on half her
popularity rating how do you explain
that
oh the answer the answer is she i mean
the short answer to george is she's
not she is a lot better politician than
boris johnson
and certainly a lot a lot better
politician
at the politics of pandemic and you know
it's a whole combination of things that
i began to mention so crucial thing
number one about
about this situation now the uk
government has on a number of occasions
most obviously do
with test and trace over-promised and
under-delivered
that undermines people's confidence uh
in you
two uh this is a government uh the uk
government
has boris johnson deeply reluctant to
admit
mistakes ptosis has come to it to say
well the scientists didn't really
understand the virus totally well back
in march
so we didn't make the right decisions
then nicola sturgeon keeps on saying
even in her party conference speech
two weeks ago saying you know that i've
had sleepless nights
this is difficult um yes i know we've
made
mistakes we've done our honest best i
haven't heard our often
uh concern well you know
numerous times numerous times you must
be listening you must be listening
you must be listening more closely uh
than than me
let me ask a bigger question simply that
when
when when the opposition parties in
scotland ask questions and they've been
repeatedly asking questions about how
the government is handling things et
cetera et cetera
she does at least i think give at least
a and
tries to give an answer to the question
you may not always think it's a
satisfactory answer
whereas of course as you would have seen
if you've been following fmq's
at all you know boris johnson looks
scours at kirsten
saying why dare you ask me these
questions and
uh as laughing nobody scolds these
questioners like nicola sturgeon sir
john
well maybe but the point is he then
tried instead of instead of trying to
answer kirsten's questions
he tries to keep costly to turn the
tables and one of the things about the
politics of a pandemic
is that sure one of the you know
oppositions have to be careful because
at the end of the day all of us
want the government to succeed so
opposition's being
awkward and difficult you know that
that's going too
far but equally
it also follows from this in a sense
this is all something about
endeavor in which we we all agree about
the objective
is that governments also should not be
playing politics with pandemic
and you know with the comments on
captain hurt captain hindsight etc
boris johnson cannot stop himself from
playing politics with pandemic
whereas nicolas sturgeon everything i
mean nicholas sturgeon's not going
around saying i think boris johns has
done an absolutely awful job
at hanging the coronavirus she almost
frankly just allows him to speak for
himself
but the point is she's she's
demonstrating a degree of sensitivity
to the positive pandemic which is you've
got having to put it slightly
differently
you've got to act like a states person
not like a politician
i never associated her with sensitivity
but it's a game of opinions
but let me ask the bigger question um
the snp by any standards
are objectively in a lot of serious
trouble
inside their own party the alex salmond
affair
yeah the contradictions in the moral
sturgeon version of events
even under the one duvet they can't
agree
on what happened uh in the alex almond
affair
the collapse of bifab the fiasco over
the ferries
uh the uh care home crisis the exam
fiasco
uh derek makai
magari ferrier it's one damn thing after
another
and yet and yet according to you they're
still doing really well and uh in public
opinion how do you account for that
um well i mean two to two things george
because you know all those things
undoubtedly are different is the smp and
in a sense almost undoubtedly the
biggest problem the snp
face at the moment is their own internal
arguments and dissension and potential
disagreements
uh surrounding alex summoned and what
should be plan b for independence etc
are undoubtedly our tensions there which
certainly pose a risk to their position
between now and the story poverty
elections in may
but at the moment much more important
than
either of those two things is one
brexit which the smp clearly
opposed the labour party is still
somewhat on the fence about
the liberal democrats um are still
trying to pick themselves up off the
floor
and the conservatives in scotland are
forced to back
so they've got a clear field largely on
that subject and they've got the vast
support of remain voters in scotland and
the second thing that they have
it's much more you know it comes back to
the coronavis
and you know as compared with whether or
not
the scottish government is thought to
have had with coronavirus better
all those other things that we can
criticize this guy's coming for about
handling fish shipyard contracts even
the attainment gap for schools
where it was coming under pressure in
public opinion before the pandemic
they're all frankly look like small beer
i think in the eyes of the electric
as opposed to the big issues and the big
issues
are coronavirus and brexit and so far at
least on those
two big issues the smp are emerging
have just been strengthened immeasurably
by both those two developments and yet
if they had succeeded in 2014 scotland
would have left the european union
instantly and without a deal
well that of course was part of the
argument for 2014 defense referendum
something around which of course there
wasn't necessarily agreement
um but you know put it turn it around
the other way george it's not to the
advantage of the unionist side
but in 2014 voters were told that the
only way to keep scotland inside the
european union was to vote no that
uh the fact that that in the end did not
prove to be true
has undoubt and undoubtedly represents a
continued
hole under the water of the good ship of
the united kingdom so far as public
opinion scotland is concerned
given that scotland is basically two to
one in favor of remain
now uh we're told by nicola not to book
a summer holiday next year
but we're also told there'll be a
referendum next year
uh so we can't go on holiday but we can
have a referendum will that happen
i'm very surprised if the referendum
happens next your party to do with
the pandemic which obviously it's
uncertain as to how quickly the country
is going to be vaccinated
um but also i think at the end of the
day you know if the uk government at
least
well i mean either if the uk
government's been persuaded to do
something i'm not sure the uk government
will want to want it to happen straight
away they'll want to play it long
and alternatively if the uk government
is basically
um finds his position undermined because
the s p managed to persuade
the supreme court that the scottish
parliament can hold a
referendum under its own remit that
legal process will take a little while
to go through so
i would be very surprised as a
referendum in 2021 but 2022
possibly depending on lots of water
flowing under lots of bridges
well i'm ready whenever professor sir
john curtis
it's been a pleasure indeed an honor
disagreeing with you thanks for
joining us on the mother of all talk
shows let me take
just a 60-second break count them
radio sputnik
[Music]
in a media landscape filled with
so-called journalists acting as
stenographers for their billionaire
bosses
there is a desperate need for news
analysis and perspectives that bug the
status quo
and get to the heart of how domestic and
international events
impact you and me as well as showing how
we can get involved in the struggle
to change that status quo check out by
any means necessary on radio sputnik
monday through friday from 2 to 4 p.m
eastern to hear the stories and voices
that mainstream media refuses to tell
you
and join us as we connect the political
social and economic movements shaping
the world around us that's by any means
necessary monday through friday at two
to four pm eastern
right here on radio sputnik
hello pizza express woking
what is it you want oh you want an
ill-advised interview on the bbc
a cheese pizza extra immature and a raw
bailout
no we don't take taxpayers money yeah
but we do take contactless
would you like a receipt for that mr
[Music]
prince
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
well the poll is pretty unequivocal are
the snp getting away with murder a
yes 84 percent up one
b no nine percent down one c
couldn't care less still at seven
percent you can vote on that until the
end of the show ben says why can police
scotland
prosecute 70 people last week for
violating travel restrictions
yet still cannot do the same for you
know who
six weeks after the event that would be
margaret ferrier uh the uh for now
mp for rutherglen and hamilton west
derrick says we get the message george
you don't like the snp give it a rest or
i'll be turning off again
be my guest derrick even better why not
call
up and take issue with me and julie says
most certainly the snp are dangerously
out of control
who is going to reign them in hold them
to account for lies
smoke and mirrors and misuse of covet
support
money disrespect and whitewash of the
salmon inquiry
to name just a few the coalition
campaign
needed to create a new coalition
government
and hillary says i think the snp are
equal to the tories
both are responsible for far too many
deaths
i hate how nicola sturgeon pretends to
be on top of everything
when it's obvious she is out of her
depth
just like boris johnson let's hear from
graham in airshow
go ahead graham hi george good evening
good evening
i wanted to add european monologue in
regards to the snp
tonight um you did a great job of
highlighting
some of the more nefarious actions i've
been taking part and
but um contrary to the poll which has
obviously
said that they're getting away with
murder there i think the the actual
public perception more broadly is
slightly different
unfortunately sure that's what sir john
was just
explaining yeah i missed that excuse me
sorry
anything john said but um yeah fifty
percent in the polls last i
read was uh what they were sitting at in
terms of um
electoral intentions yeah so um that
aside
there was also a poll which said that
sturgeon
was seen to have done a good job of
handling the pandemic
yeah john said more than 60 think she's
done a good job
even though john concedes that she
hasn't done any better a job
than boris johnson has and that's saying
something graham
yeah and i think i don't know if john
mentioned this but it was only 25
percent said the exact same thing about
boris johnson despite the policies being
pretty much
the same well certainly the same outcome
both disastrous
absolutely absolutely um so yeah behind
that that
pr she has excellent in the pr you've
got your hand well you are paying for
40 spin doctors graham 40
4-0 in a country of five million people
yeah but i'd say that all um and they're
certainly making their minds work their
again well especially with the broadcast
media i mean the scottish broadcast
media
the bbc and even worse stv
are frankly mouthpieces for nicola
sturgeon
i know one thing they haven't picked up
on that i wanted to raise that will
raise
a little second i hope um people up and
down the country will hear in scotland
that might change some of that polling
perhaps
um but this week jason leach
uh he's the the advisor to the scottish
government he's a dentist
a dentist and a professor of public
health i don't know how he became a
professor of public health must have
been
collect five packets of crisps and
become one or something but
um he was the one that told us we should
go to the stereophonics gig
and we should go to uh was murrayfield
that game
he endorsed both those things yeah he
died and he was asked later on with the
scotland
israel game went to penalties if he
would consider extending the curfew and
the pubs
um to later on so people could watch the
the
game and he said well we'll look into
that i mean what
what do you mean you'll look into it
anyway um
what he was saying this week was uh
there was a study that found that
genomic modelling
had found that scotland had almost
eradicated the virus
over the summer holidays and of course
we made some big sacrifices to achieve
that
and we can see what happened in the end
because now
we're we're obviously got the the
backlash um
of another outbreak since then and i
think this is this is the key here
because this is where the betrayal lies
if you you remember the william walsh's
at the border they were going to stop
the english coming in and spreading the
nasty virus and all the rest of it
at the same time sturgeon kept the
airports open
now i have heard that said that the
scottish government has no powers
to close the airport i don't know if
that's true or not but either way
i didn't exactly see nicola sturgeon uh
using the billy pulpit to demand that
the airports were closed either and she
was on the other night then once you're
saying that another thing was they
opened the schools
earlier than the rest of britain which
was the plan all along this that's
the scottish schools go back earlier
anyway but they went back after
promising
that we were going to have a blended
learning model that never came to
fruition no and
and the laptops what happened to them
but the biggest contributor
to the autumnal boost to the virus
was her demanding that all the students
come back to the halls of residence
so that the halls wouldn't lose the
rental income
that's absolutely right and we found
that with um
i think it was a chain of emails between
um
sort of forgotten her name uh the health
minister
gene freeman dean freeman i wish i could
forget it
yes and i think it was a was it not a
partner who'd something to the
universities have forgotten our position
but
um that's another scandal i don't think
people really heard about this is this
is what i really wanted to bring up that
i think everyone should know because
all along the scottish government has
maintained that the schools were
safe children can't transmit the virus
the values can't transmit in schools
who knows why but that's what they've
maintained now this week this is the
this is the telltale here
despite seeing that there's a school in
scotland right now
called saint matthews and sulk it's not
far from where i am in here sure
that has been closed and it was closed
and they this is what the the council
said it was closed after a discussion
with the nhs
and crucially the scottish
government now why would the scottish
government close a school
because of an outbreak if the schools
are safe
that is an admission that the schools
are not safe and i wanted to quote you
something if you can bear with me for
just one second it's just a little
paragraph
from john swinney's contribution to the
education committee and this was whether
or not the schools would be closed early
for christmas
and the scottish government had toyed
with the idea but ultimately decided not
here's why according to john swaney
there were concerns about the message
which would be inconsistent with
scottish government's emphasis on school
safety
and on keeping schools open clarity and
consistency of message were seen to be
important factors
causing schools for a three-week period
to reduce transmission
would undermine the consistent message
that schools are safe and would serve to
amplify
the concerns that had already been
expressed by
teachers about the safety of working
in schools quite so graham great call
from ayrshire thanks for that richard is
in manchester go ahead richard
hello george thank you very much indeed
for taking my call welcome
it's about the whether i'm qualified as
an englishman to speak about scotland
we're in britain here goes
um mrs sturgeon's uh supposed to be this
great democrat
and yet you know probably in the olden
days she'd have had a head cut off for
threat in a future king when william
went up with his wife
to do offensively uh a pr job and say
thank you very much and her turning on
him
as uh wow a lot of the people really
really
we don't hold with people getting their
heads chopped off of course
but it wasn't it was a bit risky for her
i thought because william and his wife
are
really quite popular yes and i think
that's
uh that's done uh uh sturgeon no good
whatsoever with uh with the people
who do not or nearly do not believe
in in a new a new referendum
i think that she's done untold damage
and then with her
um business with her husband and alex
uh as you put it tonight uh threatening
his life because if he had been sent
down
i've never seen him again no you never
would i know
and uh and the threats that we're
getting from uh ian blackford and alan
smith and people like that
in the comments i've never seen anything
like that in all my years of
of watching and listening and being
attentive to the political situation
mainly as well throughout the world now
i i've never heard anything like that
pride comes before a fall i hope uh but
they're definitely
got their uh tails up uh and they're
going for it yeah well you can't really
uh fault them for that but is that
there's a way and there's a means of
doing this
for it because they said it was
sometimes they said a once-in-a-lifetime
uh referendum in 2014
but they actually signed a document
that it was once in a generation but
they didn't wait 24 hours after
losing 55 45
in the referendum in 2014 before
demanding another one
so i do i do blame them uh for it
they haven't existed in that opinion i
agree but when the covert thing happened
everybody said oh we'll all get together
and have a joint
parts party support and since then
the whole thing has gone down and down
and down because
everybody's kicking people they've
politicized it george to a
a terrible degree and i'm disgusted with
most of them because let's look what's
happened
in america if i could trump is out
this new guy comes in what is he going
to do to stop the death what is he going
to do
to stop the coronavirus i don't see how
he can do anything
he doesn't even know he doesn't even
know he's in richard thanks for the
call uh stephen is in glasgow go ahead
stephen
good time of day again to you george i
hope you're well sir thank you
yeah i just wanted to touch on your a
quite fascinating conversation with
professor
curtis there earlier um you raised
the kind of a question about how the smp
have not quite come out come up smelling
your roses but you know they've taken
certainly less flack
than perhaps boris johnson sure
and um i i totally agree with you there
i actually agreed i
agreed overall with a lot of professor
curtis's points but i did agree with you
on the
general feeling in scotland which is not
a good one
uh towards the first minister right now
i'm skeptical about the polls uh stephen
i didn't want to
undermine uh the professor's uh faith in
the
polls but most of these polls are
carried out
at the behest of snp front
organizations and actually carried out
on the behalf of those front
organizations
by a leading snp politicians
public opinion poll company it's not my
experience
that's all i can say and i speak to
hundreds of people
in scotland and i don't get the same
outcome
as the polls get yes exactly and
it goes back to you know lies damned
lies and statistics and i'm always very
skeptical of polls anyway you know the
you know the faulty terms of reference
that are
exactly the question is always a fake
question
if you ask people do you want to leave
the united kingdom
you get a big majority saying no i don't
yes if you ask the question should
scotland be an independent
country then you get a different result
so you know in the in the absence of
a proper referendum official and legal
um we're in two minds of what the
settled will
is yes and i i did find myself
uh agreeing with you on that what i
agreed with professor curtis was the uh
the 2014 referendum there we don't want
endless referendum i've seen where that
that leads
it's divisive but the the false promises
regarding europe which professor curtis
uh spoke about was a big thing for me
you know the only way you can guarantee
staying in
and there is a big distinction i think
george between
this is the kind of thing i'd like to
postulate is the answer to your own
query the professor
that i think they have they have such a
support
because they're a single issue party
people you know a lot of people in
scotland want independence therefore
they they vote snp but the the problem
with that is that that
that's maybe a false reflection on
sturgeon
it's a false positive yes exactly for me
exactly for me
the the virus and
brexit make scottish independence an
even more fool's errand than it was
before because if scotland were to be
allowed
and there are many many pitfalls to this
uh to join the eu you'd have scotland
one part of an island in the eu
and another part of the island not in
the
eu and you expect to have normal
relations
with the country england that with which
you do
65 of your trade you expect to have an
open border
when you've got free movement of cheap
labor into scotland but england
will not allow that free movement of
cheap labor
so to me brexit and the virus both
make uh so-called independence
uh more foolish thanks very much for the
call
uh line two brian in glasgow go ahead
brian
hi george hi george i'm really getting
tired
for example this creation of a necro
student and they
have perception or performance
uh i mean i've been trying to get
the government a to account on scrutiny
of its failure of the law
for 20 years and so through that i'm
asking
many ways to prove that the reason why i
think the snp
dominate is because of our failure of
any credible legislators anywhere in the
whole damn parliament
and that's coupled with a failure of any
journalism
i wish i'd made that point uh brian uh
it's not just that the opposition
parties in scotland are
pitiful to say the least but the
the journalism that has allowed
this and sir john accepts this
this false perception that nicola
sturgeon has done
better than the uk government on the
coronavirus
well the journalists are to be blamed
for allowing that
she gets five days a week uninterrupted
live television coverage on the bbc
for 10 months the failure
here of what we're both agreeing must go
down to the level
of basic competence communication
and no scrutiny of each other no
self-checking is just a journalistic
piece
am i answering the question as a from a
book journalist and can i give an
example of that
yeah quickly and and mindful on here so
i won't go into the detail
i have registered with police scotland
an incident
and that incident was dated the 20th of
september
this year and that pertains to the
performance
and the thing is i don't even need to
argue with anybody about this now
because it's axiomatic fact and now that
police scotland has
if you like release the cracking of due
process
it is a done deal and so hopefully by
the time you come up
and i hope do challenge the seat of
misfario
who not only diminishes the credibility
of
nicholas sturgeon but unfortunately an
unfortunate for police scotland and i
don't think they should be held
a and pure judgment because of their
performance in comparison the other
breaches of the covenant i think that
again shows
that they're under the carryboard
stations we are shut down
a very fair point brian the hour is late
though thanks for the call richard is in
georgia
uh on u.s politics go ahead richard
hello again george i have some
information about uh the
people's party which i discovered here
okay i first want to make i first want
to make a very quick
uh uh kind of joking uh complaint about
uh garland uh nixon
yeah uh he's hard to he's hard to follow
because every
brilliant idea and analysis i come up
with
he says it before me and he says it
better he's wonderful i must say
he's absolutely wonderful and i'm going
to add something to his point about
whether trump
i kind of also think trump may not want
to win this these uh
these senate races and another reason is
is that uh
i i think it kind of wrangles him a bit
that uh mitch mcconnell
as uh as leader of the senate would be
the most powerful republican
in washington and uh you know possibly
the country
so that's that's not yeah
it's an odd situation i feel the
democrats don't want to win
the georgia by-election because that
would remove their alibi for not
actually doing anything
of any great importance and donald trump
as the
effective leader of the republican party
he doesn't want the republicans to win
yeah i agree with that it's a strange
situation where nobody wants to win
exactly but i do i do want to report
that
since last week i've done some research
and i have found there is a people's
party
uh in in america there's a movement
towards a people's party i knew that
yeah that's that's right that is uh but
they did just
uh the the membership which is uh i
think they have members in all states i
mean you know they have
we're building a grassroots movement
here and they have settled on the name
people's party
so that's a start that's a good good
name a good name richard thanks
thanks for the call my friend david
you're correct yeah go on go on richard
last point
could i yeah could i say nick brana is
the name of the founder
and you might want to get him on your
show how do we spell how do we spell
brana
okay thanks very much for that richard
much obliged
david is in north london on julian
assange
go ahead david hello george thanks for
taking my call
um yeah i'm i'm a a grassroots
supporter of julian assange i got i'm
interested in the case
back in uh april of last year when he
was pulled out
of the embassy um up until then i hadn't
taken
too much notice of it um i knew roughly
what was going on
um but i didn't understand um
that you know i had a sense that there
was something wrong
but i wasn't too worked up about it and
then
when he was pulled out i got much more
interested in it
and learned that it's actually a very
very important case
um and i just wanted to um talk to you
about how
how important that case is um
uh you know there's been a lot of debate
since then about
brexit covid climate change all kinds of
very important things
um but there's been near silence
in the media coverage of what's happened
in the years
before in the years since um
so you know if if we compare the silence
to the importance of the case it's a
it's a striking difference
um and if you think first of all um
think about why there's silence and
trivial coverage of the case
i mean it could be because it's not a
very interesting case
um which i don't believe or it could
hint that there's something
very wrong it's a conspiracy the
the criminals have made a crime to
report
on the crimes that they committed and
that's what the julian assange story is
about it's
intended to have and it has had a
chilling
effect on free speech and journalism
in britain and beyond yeah
and that's um it's not just an abstract
point i
i that that's exactly what i wanted to
get to because it's it's not
important just for julian assange it's
not just a an
an abstract thing it that's important
for all of us because
it means that if we're if reporter if
if if reporters aren't telling us
about what is really going on and going
wrong when governments are doing bad
things
then we only know really what our
governments want us to believe there's
quite
the antithesis of uh journalism david
the hour is late
and there is a legend on the line it's
norma
in bristol norma welcome hello george
um wow i didn't really agree with two of
your earlier comments
please tell me well the first is william
and kate's visit to edinburgh
yeah and around the country i
didn't agree with their visit um
you know the employees of the nhs
they're very overworked and they're very
underpaid they were very enthusiastic
about the
visit norma well they might be but i
mean we're all individuals i just found
them a bit patronizing
and to be honest well i'm not a royalist
and neither i think are you
uh but most people in the country are
and i
i can assure you that uh william and
kate
are a lot more popular than most of the
people
at the top of the british state yeah i i
don't mind them but i
actually thought they had a great big
train in which to travel did they need
that
and i actually think it's what i call a
bit shallow sincerity because
if they just said oh dear we think you
work hard and
you know you've got had a bad time um
you are overworked you are under people
they can't say that i know but
i just did i just didn't like it okay
and the other thing the other thing is
these navy ships
oh yes around the sea yes um
i think it's a bit provocative do you
think you can
uh do you think that anyone should be
allowed to come in and
and take the fish in our water not at
all no
i just think it's a bit premature to try
to deter the eu from fishing in our
waters
well they haven't done it yet they just
said that they've got this
there if there is no but the ships are
always there if uh
if if there is no deal we will guard our
waters
what would you expect them to say if
there is no deal
maybe it was premature that's my point
because surely there's another way
um i find it a bit aggressive i don't
know i think
i think the eu are the uh party that's
been
aggressive i think yeah i think the
german leadership in particular
uh is the one that's being aggressive
and i don't know maybe it's my age but i
don't like aggressive germans
no but i think the negotiation should
take a little bit longer before
the navy ships are there yeah okay
okay thank you not often we disagree but
it's a pleasure
disagreeing with a legend such as you
thank you
norma jamie is in malaga go ahead jaime
good evening george i hope you're well
yes thank you
my call again thank you that that that's
good news that's good news
um i'm calling to ask a question uh
last week the united nations have called
again
for the release of julian assange who as
we all know
is held in solitary confinement in a
cell
in belmar's prison which has got ramped
rampant coronavirus infected prisoners
and the united nations are being ignored
yet again by the uk government
they did a report back in may 2019 where
they called on the uk government to
release him immediately and compensate
him
and yet they've been ignored and it
appears they're going to be ignored
again
why is that george well the british
government is enthralled to the
government
in washington and the government in
washington
asked for julian assange head
on a plate and that's what the british
at least at this level of the judiciary
appear ready to
offer them at the same time of course
ann sakulas who killed a young british
citizen
uh and whom britain has demanded uh
be extradited here to face legal
proceedings
uh that has been refused
so that's the short answer to your
question
jamie and i can only spare a short
answer
because of the hour but thanks
very much for reminding us of the
consistent
position of the united nations and the
multiple uh international fora
for the release of julian assange uh
it's a pity that
there was not more of a clamor here in
britain
from his fellow journalists including
those
journals with whom he collaborated
mightily
and who feasted on the dripping roast of
the exclusives
that he produced and i think people in
britain at least know the newspaper
to which i refer tariff is in new
orleans
let's hear from tariff go ahead
how you doing george thanks for taking
my call welcome brother go ahead
duke trump had two had two comments i
mean to me i have two comments trump
tweeted out something yesterday he we
tweeted a person
saying that trump should retweet should
um um what you call that um declassify
everything
then trump responds by saying i have
been doing this
and i agree that's his tweet from
yesterday i saw my second comment
in my second comment um they had a
journalist called a dog journalist
that deal with like top secret things
dealing with the jfk assassination
said that trump signed the national
security memorandum with jeff k
had signed some years ago dealing with
um
the uh deeper excuse me to uh
take all operations away from the cia
yeah put it underneath
the department of defense so if trump
signed that
from what i understand that january 5th
that's when they're going to become
activated that's sad that's very good uh
news uh tariff uh i hope it comes to
pass i hope he's not blocked in some way
is the president
still uh i hope he's not uh
disposed of before he can do it
in one way or another uh i myself
communicated to donald trump early in
his
earlier in his presidency
that it would be a service to america
would be a service to humanity
and it would be a service to him uh if
he were to
unlock the conspiracy that killed
bobby kennedy which is extremely
damaging
to the democratic party in
california extremely damaging to the
then governing circles many of whom are
still
effectively the governing circles today
extremely damaging to the deep state in
the united states
that has done so much damage to donald
trump
he didn't agree to do that but now that
we
or he knows what he knows i hope that he
will do that
i hope we have a festival of
revelations by donald trump
of the past crimes of the american
empire
including crimes against their own
people
against their own political leaders
against their own
president in the case of jack kennedy
and the man who might well have been the
president
and changed the course of everything had
he not been cruelly murdered
in 1968 i refer of course to senator
robert kennedy beseech donald trump
to pardon julian assange to pardon
edward snowden to blow the whistle to
open the windows
and let the sunlight in on the dark
dismal disgraceful conduct
of the united states of america he'd be
remembered well
if he did good night
[Music]
you